this is jaco podcast with echo Charles
and me Jocko Willick good evening echo
good evening
and tonight's podcast is a little bit
different but I think it has some good
information in it I was asked by two
people who have outstanding podcasts of
their own to sit down and have a
conversation about leadership and
specifically leadership inside of
atrocities and when we recorded it I
wasn't really expecting it but we
decided that we would all release it on
our podcasts platforms so the two people
that I recorded this with are Danielle
Ebel Ellie and Daryl Cooper
unfortunately echo Charles was not
present for this recording and Danielle
Ebel Ellie first of all he's a history
professor he's a martial artist he's an
author and yes he's a podcaster he has
two podcasts that are great to listen to
the great podcast one is called drunken
Taoists and the other one is history on
fire
they're great podcast they're
entertaining podcasts they're
educational
they're like I said they're super
informative and the podcast that you're
about to listen to is based on a couple
other podcasts the first one being by
Danielle II from his history on fire
podcast number 32 alpha 32 a for
civilians out there and the the podcast
is about the Sand Creek Massacre which
took place in present-day Kiowa County
Colorado on November 29 1864 where there
were about somewhere between 70 and a
hundred and seventy Cheyenne Arapaho
Indians mostly women and children
who were slaughtered by a 675 man force
of the Colorado us volunteer cavalry
brutal situation horrible situation and
like I said Danielle Ebel Ellie talks
about that on his history on fire
podcast number 32 alpha the other
podcast this is related to is from
Darrell Cooper's podcasts his his
podcast is called the martyr made
podcast and specifically podcast number
10 it's about the meal I massacre and
that is when about 500 innocent
civilians again mostly women and
children were murdered and many also
raped and mutilated by US soldiers in
Vietnam
Darrell Cooper is also an incredible
podcaster he's a great storyteller and
he goes through ridiculous I would say
gaps to give all perspectives of a story
and his podcast martyr made is fantastic
he doesn't put him out off as often as I
wish he would
but the podcasts are great the one on
the palestinian-israeli conflict that he
started his first I think it's his first
six podcasts on Margaret made that's
what it's about and they're fantastic
and he's a veteran of the US Navy he's a
wrestler he's a jiu-jitsu player and
he's really smart well-read person and
great to listen to and then the last
podcast is my own podcast chocolate
podcast number 31 for hours in me lie
which is what I did an assessment of a
book by that name and talked about that
same massacre in Vietnam and in this
podcast that you're about to listen to
the three of us discuss how these
atrocities come about and what can be
done to prevent them in the future so
that's the lay down and here it is
Daniele Jocko everybody I'm here Darrell
Cooper talking it two of my favorite
people
we're gonna go some dark places today
you've listened to the last two podcasts
at Danieli and I have put out and maybe
about 60% of the podcast that Jacko's
put out and you know we're gonna we're
gonna dive into some dark places I want
to get it started pretty quick we've
been talking beforehand so let's just
jump right into it
Danielle and I recently did a series
that we cooperated on where he covered
the Sand Creek Massacre in 1864 some US
Army soldiers massacred some Native
Americans in Colorado I did the meal I
Massacre similar situation 104 years
later in the jungles of Vietnam we're
fortunate enough to be here with Jocko
if you don't know who Jocko is I guess
we'll go ahead and let you introduce
yourself just a little bit yeah my name
is John Kirwan link I was in the
military for 20 years and retired in
2010 and now I written a couple books
and have a podcast called jockle podcast
because I don't get really creative with
the names of things so Jaco is pretty
direct about things so he's also kind of
humbled Jocko as a Navy SEAL commander
in Iraq he led Task Force bruiser is
that right into task unit bruiser into
the Battle of Ramadi if you know
anything about the war in Iraq you know
battle Ramadi in the Battle of Fallujah
are probably the the two big fights that
get mentioned the most but or as
Fallujah was more of a direct assault on
the city after after the insurgents
captured and tortured and mutilated some
US contractors and Bush ordered the
Marines to retaliate the Battle of
Ramadi was a little bit different
Jaakko is gonna talk a little bit about
the environment that they went into
going into it and so he's got some
military experience not only being on
the ground but of leading men in battle
in an environment and insurgent war
where you've got different groups of
people different sects the Sunni and the
Shia in Iraq who were fighting a bloody
battle that we're in the middle of but
who we can't engage with on their level
you know these are people who were
fighting a very very dirty and ugly war
against one another and against us if
they get their hands on us as Americans
going into a war like that we've got it
we've got a different mentality we try
to avoid behaving in ways that dishonor
us and something that Jocko takes very
seriously and he had to let lead men
into combat under those conditions so
we're gonna talk about that was 2006
April of 2006 when you led your men into
Ramadi to begin with right yes yeah
that's what was so shortly before that a
couple months before the golden dome
with the Alucard Mosque was blown up by
al Qaeda and Iraq as our cow ease people
this is an ancient Shia mosque one of
the most sacred places two Shia Islam
well well interestingly Ramadi was is
primarily Sunni in fact it's almost all
Sunni and interestingly the majority of
the military forces in Iraq especially
the army or or Shia and so you had to
kind of diffuse that tension on a pretty
regular basis to make sure that there
weren't you know reprisal killings and
the there was definitely some level of
mistrust between the Sunnis that lived
there in the city and the Shia military
but it's definitely it's it's absolutely
it was absolutely clear that the the
Sunnis that lived in Ramadi the local
Sunnis that lived in Ramadi were much
preferred the Shia Army soldiers to the
insurgents that were there that were
being run by al-qaeda in Iraq by Zarqawi
and the likes and because what they were
doing was just savagery and you know
everything that you hear about
they were skinning people alive they
were beheading whole families they were
torturing raping and murdering the local
populace and to get them to support them
as much as they could through pure
terror and so the local populace
even though they might not have been you
know who they're they're basically going
with who's their worst enemy at the time
their worst enemy at the time was
without question al-qaeda in Iraq and so
the Shia army that was there to fight
al-qaeda in Iraq the the Sunnis were
were generally in support of what the
Army was doing there so it was a it was
a little bit different than in areas
like Sadr City where the the she is in
Sadr City were very active there's an
active fight going on against coalition
forces so yeah it's uh
it's definitely a tricky situation yeah
when when you roll into a situation like
that with American soldiers where both
sides are engaged in just a hurricane of
atrocities across the country and where
the people who are there they might be
looking to you for safety or I guess
that's a question I would have they
probably under the circumstances where
the people in the city I mean they
probably were looking to you to protect
them absolutely and and just before we
showed up just to just to kind of paint
this as clear as I can and I forget the
exact numbers and I apologize for that
but just before we showed up the
insurgents murdered it was something
like seven eight nine ten of the leading
tribal sheiks in the area and the tribal
sheiks that survived for that left they
left and so that just put the whole the
whole city you know under such a grip of
fear of the insurgents that they just
basically surrendered as much as you can
surrender which means hey if you want to
come and stay at my house and you want
to sit in my backyard and launch mortars
at the coalition forces we're not going
to say anything to you because we're
gonna we want to live we don't want to
get killed and that's what you end up
with you end up with passive support and
that's what the locals were doing they
were passively supporting the insurgents
only because they didn't want to have
their heads cut off
and so as we and and this was a
brilliant strategy that was spearheaded
by the one one ad the the ready first
brigade of the 1st Armored Division run
by a guy named Colonel Shawn McFarland
who ended up being a general and he's a
brilliant guy and a great leader
but you know his eye his attitude which
he actually got from HR McMaster which
he had employed up in tala far and and
one one eighty had actually gone into
tallow for and got in a turnover and
understood what they had done up Intel
afar and and the strategy was called
seize clear Holden belt which was going
to these enemy controlled territories
these enemy controlled neighborhoods and
stay there and so that's what that's
what the strategy was and that was a lot
different than the strategy that had
been being used up until this point not
just in Ramadi but in all of Iraq is
that strategy that some it almost seems
like looking at reading about Ramadi
from the outside as somebody who's never
been in combat it almost seems like the
goal was to go in there and establish
your dominance over the city almost to
show the people of the city that you
don't have to be afraid of these people
because they're afraid of us that's
we're gonna we have freedom in this city
we can take our Humvees and patrol these
streets and they're not going to come
out and fight us because they're afraid
of us and so you don't have to fear them
it almost seems like that was the goal
there yeah I wouldn't use the word
dominance because we weren't trying to
dominate the local populace right we
were trying to provide security for the
local populace and obviously that's a
big difference because when you start
having an attitude if we're gonna
dominate the local populace that that's
just a small step in the wrong direction
right that's a small step in the wrong
direction whereas saying hey we're here
to protect and secure and stabilize the
local populace that is that is what we
were doing yeah I think it took us maybe
a little bit longer than we wish it
would have to recognize that before you
can do anything counterinsurgency you
have to provide security to the people
you're not leaving them a choice then
they're gonna provide that passive
support right and I think that's one of
the issues that shows up with the kind
of episodes we did you know both the
story of Sand Creek and the story of
mill I you have a situation in which
suddenly some guys begin to look
everybody on the court and go the other
side as belonging to the same field why
because they are all Cheyenne or they
are all Vietnamese they are all there's
no sense that they are not all in the
same boat some people are your allies
some people are your enemies some people
are exactly what you were saying stuck
in between where I
of F to cooperate with your enemies not
because I want to but because I really
have no other choice and you cannot
treat all of them the same way and so I
think the dilemma that you are faced in
this idea of having to figure out okay
there are people the warrior to protect
those are not the people were going
after there are other people that we
need to take care of that seems to be
one of the things that was very much
missing you know that nuance that
ability to look at people who may look
the same way but they are not the same
people to look at them with different
eyes that seemed to be really what was
missing in some of the stories that we
treated we're the guys who did what they
did is because to them is like an Indian
is an Indian Vietnamese Vietnamese
whatever it's all the same doesn't
really matter and I think he's like how
do you see what leads to that point on
one side and vice versa
what is that you guys were doing to make
sure that it doesn't go to that point
where your guys would not make that
switch to that frame of mind and keep
their priorities very clear in terms of
differentiating in terms of who they are
facing and real quick can I just add a
supplement to that question because
that's kind of what I wanted to ask as
well as how do you how do you train your
men and lead your men in such a way that
they can pull the trigger when they have
to and when civilians get killed on you
know accidentally that that doesn't
destroy them emotionally right there's
got to be some kind of separation there
without having them fully enter over
into that mindset that Danielle is
talking about where you're just
dehumanizing the enemy altogether when
you have to lead your men in a situation
like that like how did you deal with
that yeah well this is leadership this
is leadership and this is leadership in
war and this is you know this this
question that you're asking is the is
the you know one of the largest possible
questions you could ask about combat
leadership and you know you I appreciate
that you guys keep referring to me but I
was I had 35 or 40 SEALs there depending
on the time and there was 5600 soldiers
and Marines were that were there that
were discriminating targets every single
day and that had
outstanding leadership that were that
were making sure that guys with less
training than my guys guys that were
younger than my guys guys that had a
tougher job than my guys in many cases
would still discriminate targets and
make sure that they were were engaging
enemy personnel and not civilians now
I'm certainly not saying that civilians
didn't get killed because civilians got
killed and it's an awful thing and it's
one of the things I talk about all the
time if you go to war and you're not
comfortable with the fact that you're
gonna kill innocent people then you
probably don't have the will to go to
war and maybe what you're going to war
for isn't doesn't meet the threshold of
what warrants or and and if that's what
the conclusion you come to that's fine
you know let's hope you come to it
before you've before you beyond before
you're on the ground and blood has been
spilled but there's so many little
things to that would that would that you
know that we'd cover to talk Amin just
even the distinction that I just made
between like hey we're going in there to
dominate that that's a little step it's
one little step and using that word and
then following it up and we talked a
little bit about this and garrulous
listened to your podcast about the meal
I mastered and I did one about it as
well
and one of the things that that really
that I talked about in pretty great
depth because for me I had I had
incredible correlate correlation between
what happened in me lie and when I
sometimes saw happen overseas and that
was with the intelligence that you're
receiving and you could see and I
pointed it out in my podcast and I don't
remember like all the exact verbage but
you know at the senior levels of
intelligence the intelligence report was
that pinkville or the area of pinkville
or me lie whatever you want to call it
me lie for at that area the the initial
intelligence was you know suspected
Vietnamese in the suspected Vietcong
area could be possible you know Vietcong
and then it went down one level in the
chain of command
and the next people that briefed it it
was you know just a little bit stronger
you know it was the you know Vietcong
area Vietcong controlled area and then
it went down one more level and it was
Viet Cong headquarters area and then it
got down to this is all Viet Cong and
then they threw in the the fact that you
know the the the the people going to the
market right it's market day you know
that started off as hey some people will
be at the market on this day and by the
time it got to the guys on the ground it
was everyone that's good is gonna be at
the market everyone that still in the
village is gonna be bad they're gonna be
VC and well you know what to do with VC
yeah what it says is really interesting
in terms of just you want communication
now in that case before you even go
about Americans and Vietnamese you even
discuss war or lead just the basics of
human communication now some time
starting one degree off before you know
it if you keep it long enough that one
degree off took you so far off course
from the reality they are trying to
describe that the words which it's kind
of like playing telephone you know when
you whisper something in the other
person's hear it doesn't sound that
different from what you just stirred by
you just week it's a tiny bit by the
time you are down 20 people the message
has no similarity whatsoever to the
original one and it seems like that as I
think we do it all the time in daily
life but nobody dies as a result of it
whereas in that kind of scenario people
do die the consequences are so much more
dramatic as a result of that and what's
interesting is and Darrell you kind of
brought up in your podcast and and you
did as well Daniel E is how does this
happen
right how does this happen because if
you take a normal human being and you
drop them into the middle of that thing
they look around and they go what the
hell's happening which is which is
actually what happened when when Hugh
Thompson came in his helicopter he
dropped into this situation and said
what the hell's going on here this is
totally wrong
but as you're as you're getting there if
you're not on that trip if you're not on
that train as it's going off the rails
you you don't recognize it and that's
why one thing I talk about all the time
from a leadership perspective is the
ability to detach from all the chaos and
all the mayhem that's happening because
if you don't have to if you don't have
the ability to detach from that chaos
you're in it and if you're in the chaos
as a leader you don't see the mayhem
that's happening and so it's so
important for a leader in the business
world but certainly in the military to
be able or in any leadership position to
be able to step back and and observe
what's actually happening from a
detached perspective because otherwise
you're in the storm and that is not a
good place to be as a leader you've got
to have rules for how you're gonna
behave before while you're going into it
because if you just you know if you're
gonna react everything on the ground
once you arrive I mean it's always more
expedient to just shoot them you know at
the time it's always easier and safer
probably to just do the easy thing and
be violent or whatever so you have to
have rules going into it um
yeah one thing that I want to the point
he brings up is super interesting but I
think essentially what you're saying is
that the person in a position of
leadership needs to be a Zen master you
know they need to be in the middle of
emotions that clearly are affecting
everyone around them and they are
bombard they are getting bombarded with
those emotions they need to be
completely detached from this stuff it
makes perfect sense how do you do it
because it's a hell of a lot easier said
than done clearly and how do people even
train to get to that place so well for
one thing when I was running the
training for the West Coast SEAL Teams I
would fire up that training to a point
that it was there was total temptation
for the leaders to get wrapped into the
scenarios that I was developing for them
there'd be total mayhem and if they let
it happen they would get wrapped up in
these horrible scenarios mentally
emotionally they'd be mad they'd be mad
at me because I was the guy that was
running the training they'd be mad at
the opposing force role players they
mad at their guys they'd start yelling
and screaming they'd make bad decisions
and and I wanted them to get there
because I wanted them to see what
happens when you get wrapped up in this
stuff emotionally so and then what I
would do is teach them that they have
certain what I would call red flags
certain certain signals that they need
to learn how to pick up yeah
if you feel yourself start raising your
voice well then that probably indicates
that you might getting beginning
emotional if you're breathing heavy if
your fists are clenched there's all
these things that you start to recognize
and once you can recognize them and you
say okay I'm starting to get emotional
right now need to step back now
interestingly what I would often do in
an easy methodology for training these
guys was first of all stop looking down
the sights of your weapon but you're not
allowed to and we'd give we'd give a
leader stick if we had to and take their
gun away so that they weren't gonna be
shooting they weren't gonna be wrapped
up in that tactical situation and
literally put that weapon at high port
and step back away from the firing line
you know Kali Kali is with his m16
gunning people down
he's completely wrapped up in what's
happening Medina's yelling and screaming
I mean I talked about this with with
police forces as well if you want to
hear people go listen to some of the bad
shootings that you hear and police have
a incredibly hard job they need way more
training but go listen to some of those
shootings that take place and listen to
the pitch and the tone of the officer
they've it in and what are they doing
they're saying that I don't get to out
get out there they're completely
emotional right and that emotion is
gonna drive bad decision-making so you
have to learn how to detach the way you
do it is in a way I would initially
teach guys to do it is by physically
putting their weapon at high port
stepping back away from the the actual
firing line and look moving their head
around and looking around you know the
story I wrote about in extreme ownership
is you know we I had the the Delta
platoon commander who's a great guy
mark guy you know Ivy League Naval
Academy and just just a brilliant guy
great guy and he was we were doing some
training and it was in Humvees and we
were doing immediate action drills and
Humvees are out in the desert and you're
she targets pop up and you engaged the
target so it's like it's like being mini
tank commanders and you've got five
vehicles you got to maneuver them on the
battlefield while they provide cover
fire for each other and it's it's a
little bit chaotic there's big machine
guns shooting and and when I was going
with him and I was sitting behind him
observing him do this and every time the
shooting was started he would kind of
lock up right he'd kind of like lock up
there's so much happening that he wasn't
processing it quick enough and so I took
a Sharpie magic marker and I and I and I
wrote down on the window in front of his
face I wrote okay here's what I want you
to wind when the shooting starts I want
you to this one relax to look around
three make a call and at that time I
hadn't thought through this stuff as
much as I have now because I've been
doing it for much longer
but what I was telling him to do was you
know detach from what's happening and
and the way you do that is you relax you
look around and and then you get on the
radio and you make a call and you know
the next run I watched him and I'm
sitting behind him and I'm looking over
his shoulder and once the shooting
starts you can't hear anything so I'm
just just watching him and I I see him
the shooting starts I see him look at
the window and I see him take a deep
breath and exhale I was like okay he
just relax and I see his head start to
turn and I realized okay now he's
looking around and and and he that those
two simple items were enough to make him
detach from all that chaos actually
assess what is happening and then make a
good decision and so that is one of the
most important things that you can train
a leader to do sounds like coaching a
jiu-jitsu white belt first thing you
tell them they're on the ground getting
beat on and they kind of four first so
you tell them breathe yeah just breathe
relax until you can do that then
nothing's gonna work yeah it's one of
those it's one of those things - people
talk about like breathing exercises and
one thing that I would instinctively do
and it's another thing that I would
train my guys to do was like you don't
panic
on the radio you don't yell on the radio
you don't scream on the radio you no
matter what's going on when you get on
the radio you say you know bruiser one
six this is bruiser over I mean that's
that's what you do and in order to do
that you have to relax you use so it
forces you if you're not gonna sound
panicked on the radio which which if you
sound panicked on the radio and and your
team hears it guess what you're gonna
have panic going on so you have to it's
another it's another method to detach so
when you hear your voice getting excited
when you you know when you read about
lieutenant Calley yelling and you hear
about Matina yelling that that you know
Callie started yelling likely because
Medina was yelling at him and now that's
what happens we were just we're just
sending that panic through the chain of
command and it's it's a horrible
horrible thing I think what's
fascinating about it is that the
parallels even to the scenario you are
describing is something the 99% of the
people listening ninety-nine percent of
the UM beings will never have to deal
with because they're never gonna be in
combat which bullets flying all around
them and all of that and yet it's easy
to forget that the same dynamics are
playing most people lives in ways that
they may be able to recognize in with
less extreme consequences but like when
you're a parent and you have your kids
going wild and suddenly you find
yourself you know raising your voice and
starting to yell at them and not because
I mean there's a time and a place some
time is the right thing to do is to kind
of cool them on their stuff in harsh
ways but there's a difference between
raising your voice with an intent and
raising your voice because you're losing
it and you're getting overly emotional
and you're getting angry and kids
realize it and they will leave you they
will see how you are losing your stuff
they will see how you are less of a
credible presence in their life that
they know can count on you the way
because you are wrapped in your own
emotions and you know they press a
little button and you go off sometime
they'll press that button cuz they enjoy
seeing you go of some title president
but you know the point is you're not a
good leader as a parent and it's the
same thing I mean my company now we work
with businesses all over the world and
it's the same exact thing and I teach
the same exact thing
you're starting to get mad at your
employee you start to get mad at your
subordinates if you're starting to get
mad at your boss what should you be
doing as a good leader you should be
detaching taking a step back I've told
people hey if you start feeling that way
you stand up from the meeting table just
just you know no one's gonna say hey
what are you doing you just you know
stand up stretch out step back away
these people are having a heated
argument and you start getting involved
in it instead of getting involved in it
take a step back by the way when you do
that you look like a tactical genius
because everyone else is start to lose
their temper they're starting to say
things that they shouldn't say and
you're the one that's up listening
I just just covered a book and in just
just like a little thing is if if
there's if you're talking I'm gonna let
you talk because if I let you talk I
know
twice as much as you I know everything
that you know and I know everything that
I know so I'm gonna win that tactical
situation I want to come back to what
you were just saying Daniel about
leadership as a parent it it ties into
something he was talking about a few
minutes ago with like a police officer
who's panicking we were mentioning this
on the car ride over here about police
shootings like more often than not what
you see is that they're the result of
incompetence they're the result of a
socially inept cop who can't manage the
situation and it's not an easy situation
to manage you've got a potentially
dangerous person you don't know them and
maybe they're lightly resisting you just
verbally and you've got to take control
of that situation well unless you're an
exceptionally competent and confident
person maybe the only tool you have to
bring that person under control is your
baton or whatever it is and you get the
impression in Vietnam especially once
you get up to 68 69 where you know
they're starting to just throw junior
officers in right out of you know ROTC
and just throwing them into combat and
you hear stories about officers getting
fragged you start to hear stories no
Cali washed out OCS three three times
right and you you get these people now
into a situation where you have a
military unit that recognizes they're
incompetent leadership and they're
scared they feel incompetent themselves
as a unit and you get them into a place
where and maybe this is something that
you can contrast really well because you
dealt you lead primarily
seals and marines right well seals
joking you worked a lot with marine we
worked a lot with Marines and army
soldiers as well yeah and actually
mostly there's one battalion of Marines
in inside Ramadi okay the three 8th
Marines awesome when you're dealing with
the American military today and and I
know I mean is something that gets lost
on a lot of people is that uh as highly
trained and motivated and all those
things as our Special Forces are you
know they're very specialized you guys
are you know trained for very very
specific intense missions and stuff but
you go pull an average ranger or marine
or something or infantryman you put them
in combat with good leadership and that
is a an unbelievably effective soldier I
mean American soldiers today our
all-volunteer force these are incredibly
well trained and motivated people if you
you know as if they have the proper
leadership when you get back in a
situation like that with Vietnam where
you get a whole unit in that situation
that that cops in where they're in maybe
a village they don't exactly know how to
handle this situation without resorting
to lethal force and they start to feel
threatened and everything runs off the
rails you know it's it's unrealistic to
expect just like you know you're happily
married man and you don't want to cheat
on your wife then when you're off on a
business trip after you've had a few
drinks with the co-worker that's on
travel with you
it seems innocuous maybe it's totally
innocent at the time don't go upstairs
to the hotel to watch a movie because if
you get to that point you're just
putting yourself in a terrible position
right and and in an in that military
context the idea that all of the
built-up momentum behind something like
meal I the idea that you're gonna get
right up to that moment on March 16 1968
where the only thing that stopping it
from happening is a few pounds of
trigger pull that's the last bit of you
know that's your last opportunity to
avert this catastrophe
it's just that few pounds of trigger
pull good luck with that you know that's
something that you can't let it get to
that point and that was something that
uh and I'll let you guys take it over
but I wanted to talk about something
that it was fascinating to me it's you
picked up on as soon as I said the word
tablished dominance on the streets of
Ramadi you reacted against that and
you're right that's incredibly important
and it ties in to what you were just
talking about about you would make
people either back away from the
situation or stop looking down the
sights of their gun because when you're
looking at a person down the site so
your gun it's your framing of the
situation and you haven't put down their
gun it now it's just a person it's not a
target it's not anything like that if
you've got a bunch of people going into
Ramadi and they're thinking in terms of
our job is to go establish dominance on
the streets of this city
well you're framing that in a way that
under the right circumstances could you
know lead to trouble yeah and so framing
it seems like it's what you're talking
about and and I also want to make it
perfectly clear that if the soldiers
Marines SEALs that we work with in the
Battle of Ramadi if they didn't dominate
the street as we move down it you know
we would be just be oh we be killed so
there is the job is even harder than I
made it out to sit to be because I don't
I wouldn't want to use the word dominate
the city of Ramadi but you're damn right
we're gonna dominate the space that we
go into and we're gonna do that by being
very very aggressive and so there is
this fine line and by the way you'd go
into a you'd kick a kick a door in in
Ramadi and there's there's gunfire in
the street that you're on you'd kick in
a door and there would be a mom and a
dad and a couple kids and there'd be a
normal household with green grass and a
soccer balls and that would happen that
that's what the city was filled with and
so the the fact that these guys you know
were able to flip that switch over and
over and over again was was amazing and
it's a it's a testament to do the
military forces that we have and to the
leadership I want to give equal credit
to both but to your point about hey you
know me lie these were draftees there
was hundreds of thousands of draftees
that went over there and did an
incredible jobs they were well led that
stood up when people in when the wrong
things were happening so
this was a horrible scenario Danieli
let's follow up on that then I mean
that's cuz that's what's the difference
like what happens you didn't get all the
Psychopaths in the army and round them
up into one unit right by all accounts
the guys at meal I talked to they were
the type of people that when the folks
back in Kansas heard about what happened
they couldn't believe that little Johnny
would ever do anything like that and
same thing at Sand Creek right same
thing and so because you're right we
were talking about this on the way to
something today it is for we have
something like Abu Ghraib happens it's a
terrible situation a lot of bad things
went on there the idea though that an
entire company of American soldiers
would go into an Iraqi village and wipe
out five hundred innocent people that is
inconceivable today in the sense that so
many things would have to go wrong and
break down and degrade and degenerate in
the American military for that to have
happened that it's just it seems like a
completely different moral universe and
well you look at what the chain of
events that led to me lie it was those
and and if any of those chain of events
any anywhere along that chain of events
could have broken that whole chain
lieutenant Calley could have gotten
killed when the minefield and now you
could add someone else came in that was
a better leader and didn't have a
Napoleon complex and was able to stand
up morally to other people there's
there's so many things that could have
changed on that you know that could have
changed that whole scenario the most the
most powerful one being a different
leaders the same thing at Sand Creek
different leader that that actually
never would have happened right I never
would have happened you see that you
know you see all the guys under Silas so
like unanimously they all agree with him
whereas all the guys with Chivington
Union it's like clearly there's a
leadership element where the average guy
in those units is heavily influenced by
who's setting an example for them and
that is one of the thing that interests
me about human nature that you know one
of the things because we're discussing
like does that mean the human being you
know one of the things you hear a lot is
are human beings just evil by nature and
now they're not even the majority of
people are not there are of course the
exceptions there is that whatever small
percentage but the majority of human
beings are not evil the problem is that
the majority of human beings are
extremely easily influenced like their
moral compass can range in so many
different direction that under right
leadership they will be awesome human
beings and the wrong leadership it's not
that hard for them to start sliding down
a really dark direction so to me it kind
of is a matter of weakness
more than evil you know it's not that
these guys are complete psychopath where
you know you have dinner with them and
they are nice people and they yell to
the old lady across the street
and yet the degree while they may have
good intentions good intentions don't go
too far without crazy discipline strong
willpower a lot of the qualities that
allow you to keep those good intention
real under heavy emotional pressure
where it doesn't all fly out the windows
I I don't know what happened I just lost
my mind or hate they told me that this
was the thing to do and so I just
followed orders you know where you have
that integrity to stay present in a
crazy situation you're asking human
beings to be kind of extraordinary in
those circumstances because the ordinary
human being may go down a bad path
so the indie antidote in some way seemed
to be to make yourself extraordinary to
be to be able to withstand a kind of
situation and that's where a great
leader make a huge difference because so
many people will be like flags in the
wind you know if the wind is still think
one well they will go with it if the
wind is tilting heavily the other way
they'll also go their route and and so
that what interests me is because while
a few humans will always choose a pretty
messed-up evil side a bunch of humans
can go either way
what is that shape the kind of human
beings that will be able to be a great
leader or even just for themselves even
if they are there nobody under them just
they will make choices that in an ideal
scenario most human beings who want to
make what a separate the guy who you
know is sitting there and on the couch
say you know I would be the guy and the
guy
actually is that guy I think one of the
difficulties with that is Jaco you and
Jordan Peterson talked about this in
your podcast together you were talking
about the book ordinary men and how you
know you've got a couple guys a group of
guys there who are going to who are
being ordered to do something that's
grotesque and it's not simply a matter
of like you know that's a real good
situation if let's say you are a person
of strong moral character of just all
the things that you would want him to be
you've got two conflicting moral systems
here because you have a duty and
obligation to your fellow soldiers who
are gonna have to go do this one way or
another unless you revolt completely and
then you're betraying your country and
there's all these other things that are
brought into it that you know that are
moral things these are you know it's
moral to not want to abandon your
friends and your colleagues to have to
go do the hard work that has to be done
so that you can go nurture your
self-righteous sense of personal
morality or at least that's the type of
thinking that might go through a
person's head like that what right do I
have to put my own personal idea of
what's right ahead of my obligation as a
soldier ahead of what my country is
telling me to do ahead of just being in
there with all of my friends and fellow
soldiers and leaving it to them like
that's a moral thing that is that is
something that you want people to feel
right and I and I and I wonder sometimes
how much of these situations are filled
with people who you know maybe 90% of
them the vast majority that aren't those
few evil ones they're all kind of
looking at each other like maybe inside
they don't necessarily think this is
right or they don't want to be doing
this but they don't want to abandon
their friends and their friends are
looking at them thinking the same thing
and you just have this vicious cycle
you know orange and one of these things
yeah and part of the problem there is
the human willingness to rationalize and
make justifications for oneself it's
like well in back in because you know
when you look at the principles that
people hold like what they believe their
philosophy of life is and the way they
behave even you much more ordinary
circumstances I mean you made the
example of the cheating husband right
how many people serious
we believe that monogamy is the right
thing and you don't cheat on your spouse
there will be lots and lots and lots of
people who say yeah of course I believe
in it how many people actually live up
to it and it's like come on man that's
not nobody's shooting at you nobody
there are no it's a much more manual
situation and people in many cases came
to live up to their ideal seem very
ordinary circumstances let alone when
you start pressing the buttons and when
the circumstances are no longer ordinary
but it becomes real panic time and
stress and all of that goes up so to me
is like you need to have almost a
maniacal determination to have this code
of conduct that you will hold up no
matter what happens like I use it as
it's a joke but it's not a joke like I
use it for daily life as like to me once
I'm very few moral rules that are
absolutes but the ones that are there
are no exception so for me like if you
give your word to somebody there are no
exception is like don't give your word
unless you are a hundred and ten percent
sure you are gonna keep it don't I don't
mind you know we can have a regular
conversation and you don't give your
world but if you do give your world to
me there is no oh sorry I didn't think
in that situation or there was that
exception to me the only way you
apologize is a samurai style you know
you stick a knife in your belly and you
slice back-and-forth that's how you say
sorry there is no exception to that it's
almost as if you have those rules serve
as pull stars when you're in a situation
it's as chaotic as something like yeah
combat where you have to have a few
rules that I mean maybe they're
arbitrary but you'll die for them yeah
because when you're in the midst of a
situation that is completely outside the
realm of your normal experience they
give you reference points
you know they structure the situation a
little bit for you so you're not just
lost in chaos there's some structure to
it and then you can evaluate the rest of
the environment relative to those hard
and fast rules that you've got because
in the situation you know when you're in
me lie and you're one of the people
who's kind of on the fence no but now
people are shooting that is not the time
to have this no that's not when you're
gonna figure it out yeah sure
well this might sound really obvious and
and it is it's a very simple obvious
answer to this really really hard
question of you know how do you prevent
this thing from happening or who's the
kind of person that will stand up and
the answer is very quite simple it's
training in education it's training in
education and if people understand that
these kind of things can happen and they
get put in these pressure situations and
they get trained and they get debriefed
on mistakes that they made and they saw
that they got emotional and you trained
them correctly well then you've got
someone who gets into a meele eye
situation and and says to themselves
wait a second we're not getting shot at
right now cease fire
and and that was the the most incredible
thing about that story is that's all it
took was a one liter mm-hmm
to say hey stop killing people and they
literally stopped that moment so
training people and and putting them in
these situations and educating them so
that they understand so they have
pattern recognition training them so
they can learn how to detach training
them so that they can control their
emotions training them that they can see
when horrible things are unfolding
before them and then how that they they
can put a stop to them that is what is
important and as you mentioned Daryl as
the as the Vietnam War drove on that the
training got less and less and the
officers were getting sent over quicker
and quicker and you're getting
on-the-job training and the person that
you're getting on-the-job training from
is a person that's only been doing it
for two and a half months longer than
you and that's that's how these things
occur so you have to invest in in in
people that are gonna be in these
situations and it's the same thing again
I tell this to businesses all the time
have you done you know on a construction
site have you done a drill if you have a
mass casualty what do you know what you
know where you're gonna call in casualty
evacuation you know we're getting in
what the air of air flight our life
flight number is does anyone have the
life flight number here because if
someone gets hurt
you need to make that call and do you
know what station you're gonna call what
helicopter you're gonna call do you know
where they're gonna land why would you
not run those things
and if those things unfold and you're
not prepared for them you're gonna fall
apart and it's the same thing with these
ethical and moral situations where if
you don't understand what they are and
you don't understand what can go wrong
you'd have you'd have a bad day and I
thought it was really on what you
brought up a little bit ago when you
said there are steps along the way that
long before the crisis manifest itself
there's that ability to recognize the
tiny little steps that are leading there
now when you look at that tiny think it
looks tiny it doesn't look like a big
deal
that's no crisis that's not a problem
but it's that first step that's taking
you down that path and it's a lot easier
to stop it early then when crisis is on
and so in that sense that does become a
training that does become a thing of
like how do you recognize the steps how
do you work on it and you know you were
saying things like even something as
basic I hate one second take one second
to breathe before you react then think
how you wanna react is the same thing
that applies to everything it applied to
conversation when people are people you
care about maybe are getting you angry
do you really want to respond right away
or maybe take three seconds to take a
breath then decide how you want to
respond you know and I think is like to
me is weird as silly as that is because
you're clearly war and parenting are
very far universes in so many ways but
to me as being one of the see I think of
your kids yes I got for that son but I
guess to me has been one of the most and
forgiving mirrors that I ever had put in
front of me was seen how I react under
extreme stress when you haven't slept
for two days when somebody's throwing a
fit that's completely unjustified when
and sad then it's like yeah you have all
the good reasons to be mad but really
this is how you respond this Israel you
react to a four-year-old kid who's just
being a four-year-old kid and you get
all emotional in this story Ireland and
suddenly like 10 seconds seemed to me
blow it up I see myself from the outside
and I'm like I'm everything that I
despised in this moment you know that
man right there that's responding their
way as all there is
old I can see why doesn't matter you
still don't do it you know and rather
than just being like okay let's whip
myself on a horrible human being I
discover that is like okay what can I do
not to get there next time
you you got real-world training right
because now you recognize the situation
and now you don't let it happen anymore
exactly you know I had I was talking to
you guys earlier we I hit at my first
employment to Iraq we went and hit a
target and and it sounds almost like you
know like what you'd imagine in a movie
we'd get handed a map then on the map
it'd be a city block and Baghdad and
there'd be a red X on one of the
buildings and that's all I needed
oh you want me to go hit that red X cool
we'll go hit that red X and one night we
went and hit you know the building with
the red X on it and when we hit the
target it was you know like the most
normal family you could ever imagine and
as we started talking to them and we had
our interpreter get in there and figure
out you know hey do you know who this
person is they're like yeah he lives two
doors down okay and so then I went back
and eventually said to myself a question
that if I wasn't if I had more
experience I would have to ask this
question for me I said hey I got a
question who put that red X on that
building and why and as I pulled the
string on it it you know it was one of
those things where they had gotten some
Intel which you know I won't talk about
where it came from but it was it was
Intel that you know put it in that
general vicinity and they like picked
the the center of the general vicinity
there's the center of the generals
anything over there we'll put the X and
no follow-up and so I always taught that
as something hey guys make sure you know
who's giving this intelligence and
that's that's the case that happened to
me lie where the person on if no one no
one at the platoon level said hey hold
on a second who's who's confirming that
this is a hundred percent vc in this
village a hunch you're telling me this
is a hundred percent vc in this village
that's what we're saying right now who's
tell who's saying that i want to talk to
that person and that's another thing i
talk about all the time is you don't as
a leader you don't want to be surrounded
by yes men you don't want to be
surrounded by yes
and you know we're talking about the
horrors of Vietnam War and I'm reading
another book right now there's a platoon
commander and his guys are going there
they're rotating between three locations
and two of the locations are not too bad
the other locations it's a nightmare
it's it's it's Vietnam or stereotypical
it's booby traps snipers and indirect
fire they never see the enemy they just
never see the enemy and all they do is
they go out there on patrol they get
blown up they get shot they get murdered
and they never see the enemy and the
guys are getting wounded or killed and
as you think about that I would I would
pray that if I was the company commander
or the battalion commander that that
platoon commander would come to me and
say hey Jaco this is stupid
let me tell you how many people we've
lost anytime any other the platoons have
lost and let me tell you what we've
gotten out of it we've got nothing out
of it
and we need to stop this or we need to
find a better way to do it if you want
to send us in there let us set up a
strong point let us set up a bunkered
position we'll stay and we'll observe
but us just walking around in there
waiting to get blown up makes no sense
whatsoever please let's do something
else and as a leader you have to have
the open mind to say okay I thank you I
appreciate that feedback what are your
suggestions you've been in the area of
operations how do you recommend we do it
and whenever I hear these stories of
guys that get put in really terrible
situations in the military it it sickens
my heart because what you need is a
culture inside any organization the
military yes but any organization of
people to raise their hands and say hey
wait a second this is stupid
hey wait a second do I not see an
American flag on that Indian Reservation
with a white peace flag underneath it
and wait wait hold on stop why wait wait
stop
and that takes moral courage it takes
training and it takes a culture inside
an organization to stop people and
question what they're doing and it takes
that certain level of detachment that
you were talking it absolutely takes
detachment you know it's like you were
saying about like dealing with a
four-year-old or something
when you're in the middle of it it's
seems normal it seems like the way to
behave and it's only when you step back
and say you know one of the things about
human beings are great strength they
suppose is that we're supremely
adaptable creatures I was talking to a
psychologist one time who used to work
for the State Department he would he
worked in Africa for a while he talked
about he was telling me some of the
stuff that he would encounter whole
villages where every woman had been
raped ten times over the years where
kids in this village had watched their
parents kill just horrifying stuff and
my question to him at the time because
he was a psychologist was I mean how are
these people not just completely blown
out with PTSD and everything else like
how are they functional at all given
what we know about PTSD and how it does
function under circumstances that are
far less severe than that and that's
what he said he said you'd be surprised
humans are very very adaptable and to
them this is their environment and that
can work the other way too though you
know that can work in the direction of
in the new Ken Burns Vietnam documentary
just just I don't know if you've watched
it yet I haven't watched the whole thing
yet but I watched the probably I think
the first two episodes a so one of the
ones you're coming up on the name of it
is this is what we do and it starts out
talking about the sky new recruit and he
shows up to this place and like the
first thing he sees when he gets to the
base that he's at it's not a mask or
anything like that but it's just sort of
a you know Vietnamese prisoner or
captive being led along by you know a
corporal or something and he's just
being rough with them and kind of pushed
him along and doing stuff that clearly
is outside of regulations and this new
guy shows up and he's like hey like you
supposed to be doing that or whatever it
is and the first thing he hears when he
gets over there is kid this is Vietnam
this is what we do and he said that
their whole rest of the time that he was
there when he saw something he didn't
like when he was doing things that he
wasn't sure about he just repeated in
his head this is Vietnam this is what we
do this is what we do and after a while
he didn't have to repeat it anymore
after a while that was his environment
and you know it reminds me I used to
have these recurring dreams I probably
shouldn't share this
the air but I used to have these
recurring dreams I still have them every
once in a while the details in the
setting differ but it'll be something
like the dream starts and I'm in like a
helicopter say and I'm flying around
like a city like LA or wherever and I'm
just shooting people like Grand Theft
Auto it's just like a video game and I'm
going through and I'm doing this
sometimes there's people down there I
know my friends and stuff and it's just
all it seems just like I'm in a video
game and then the way the dream goes is
at a certain point after a few minutes
of this all of a sudden it hits me what
I'm doing and I look around and I it's
almost as if I wake up in the dream and
I'm like oh my god like I'm killing all
these people what what am i doing but at
the time it was completely normal it
seemed exactly like this is just what I
should be doing or anything like that
and that's something I think that is
well it's why you told people stop
looking down the barrel of your gun you
know you got to step back and be able to
get that distance so you can change your
frame and again with the proper training
and the proper education you will know
as a leader that that behavior will
escalate that behavior will escalate and
if you allow it to happen it will
continue to get worse and so it starts
off and I've read all kinds of books
about about Vietnam especially about
Vietnam where it's it starts off it
starts off with hey the villagers are we
kind of know them everything's cool give
them lollipops but then you know one of
our guys dies and then what we're not
getting wali pops as a matter of fact
we're kicking the kids away and it only
escalates to there and it escalates to
murder and and it escalates or it I
should say this it can escalate it
doesn't automatically escalate because
all it takes is someone to step in and
say hey no that's across the line but
you know what you want slap a guy I get
it I get it but that's the line anything
once you know what one thing we used to
say and I used to tell my guys once the
cuffs are on somebody so once we get
somebody's zip tied it's over like you
do what you got to do to get a guy under
control once they're zip tied it's done
and now they're you they're getting
taken
and you you treat them firm but fair
that's it and so those lines you you
have to draw them and you have to hold
the line as a leader because things
start to escalate you know the thing
that you were asked me about earlier
about the the Chechen war and the
Russians against the Chechens and it's
they didn't they didn't hold the line
with the little things and when you lose
that discipline even up on the smaller
things
well eventually then you don't have the
discipline on the bigger things can you
go overboard with that yes you can I can
hold the discipline so hard on the
little things that no one listens to me
on the big things that's why leadership
is hard because there's a dichotomy
there that you have to balance you can't
be freaked out because you know you
didn't you didn't blouse your boots when
you were supposed to but at the same
time if I start to let too many things
slide well it will escalate and it seems
like maybe with things like that
a lot of people who were civilians they
they laugh when they see in movies or
you know TV shows or something about how
soldiers in combat are still expected to
groom themselves they're still expected
to take care of themselves and comport
themselves in a military way and what I
tell them a lot of the times is and
maybe you can confirm this because I
don't really know what I'm talking about
but is that you know my feeling on on
why that stuff is so important is that
you can't have you know you can't have
Iraq in the sectarian war and all the
stuff the storm that's going on around
them you can't have that become the
environment to which they're adapting
the environment to which they need to be
well adapted is the US military that's
their environment that's what they're
focused on following these rules and
behaving in this way and then when
that's their environment they can go
into these places and do their jobs if
they get in there and they start
reacting to what's going on around them
because I mean you then you can tell a
guy talking about going native right you
can't go native yeah once it's that's
Apocalypse Now right you can tell a guy
once the cuffs are on but you know if I
was talking to a family yesterday and
this is the guy that just cut their
heads off well I mean you know you you
can't have you
can't put yourself in a situation
because it does make sense to beat the
shit out of that guy it does make sense
to put a bullet in his head when the
cuffs are on like from even from a moral
standpoint in certain ways like that you
can justify that you know and so that's
why you can't be reacting to whatever it
is that's going on and it sounds like
that's kind of what you're saying yeah
there's actually an interesting
dichotomy there as well because you you
need to follow the rules right
because if I told if the three of us
decided hey we're gonna go on this
village raid and we're all gonna use our
morals as our guide well we have three
different scenarios your you just
admitted that you'd be executing
somebody that was already handcuffed
who knows what you'd be doing don't you
know I don't even want to know
right so so we we're all over the map
right maybe you're maybe you're saying
you're not even gonna don't even want to
handcuff anyone because you think that's
too offensive and I'm somewhere in the
middle whatever the case may be we're
all over the map so I would always tell
the guys look you need to do what is
legal what's what's legal
but then the paradox of that is
sometimes what you can get away with the
legally still isn't the right thing to
do and that's again that's why there's a
dichotomy between those two between do I
follow the rules exactly or I mean you
know look at look at me I look at Sand
Creek uh that my boss told me to shoot
this guy show told me to shoot this
three-year-old baby my boss told me to
do that I am I should I be following
orders is there a threat that I don't
know about you know these days you know
I've heard a lot of stories now the guys
that that took down Mosel right the the
enemy was sending surrendering children
to come and surrender to coalition
forces and they would be strapped with
ID vests suicide vests and over and over
and over again it was our US military
you know especially our explosive
ordnance disposal folks and that work
going and disarming these bombs on these
kids but yeah how do you feel after you
see two or three of those little kids
get killed plus two or three EOD guys
get killed and now you're going to fight
those guys and they
wanna surrender that's a very
challenging thing and if you don't
maintain discipline it's a slippery
slope and it's funny because we're
saying two things at the same time which
sound contradictory and yet that's life
on one end you need to have these super
strict rules that you are not going to
bend under any circumstances and on the
other end the thing that you rightly
point out to is the fact that real
leadership is also the ability to think
on your feet and no two situations are
alike so the rule following approach
while it may save you from some of the
worst abuses is not always necessarily
the right thing and there's also the
time when we almost follow the rules
except when we don't because that's the
one time when it's correct and that
ability to make the right call at the
right time that's what make you an
extraordinary human being we'll just
sort of in debates or popping off at the
mouth today
we sort of take for granted that the
whole I was just following orders
question was settled at Nuremberg it was
not settled at all that's an incredibly
complicated question for just the reason
you were describing you know somebody
who worked at a Nazi death camp you know
they didn't make ten thousand
independent decisions to kill somebody
they made one decision that their own
personal moral compass was going to get
outsourced to the state and that they
were gonna do their duty and follow
their orders they made that decision
once and now once you've made that
decision and you've outsourced your
moral compass which again under most
circumstances that might be the thing
that keeps you from doing the wrong
thing that might be the thing that keeps
me from executing that you know al-qaeda
guy but when the institutions themselves
start to get warped or if you're in even
even if the institution is an individual
unit or something you know it's I can't
remember where I heard it but there's a
some zoologist or somebody who pointed
out to him that he had asked why zebras
have black and white stripes when the
grass is gold colored and yellow and
they don't blend into that at all
clearly Tigers can see that and he
pointed out to him that that camouflage
isn't to blend into the environment that
camouflage is to blend in with each
other they blend with the herd and so
the Tigers have
difficult time tracking down like and
focusing on an individual and they oh
they figure that out because they wanted
to try to you know put ear clips on them
or something to track these things
around but they noticed every time they
put something identifiable on one of
them the Tigers would kill it it was
because now they had something to focus
on and so and that's you know I'm not
making a literal evolutionary comparison
here but there's an interesting like
just sort of analogy which is this
instinct to blend in with the herd
there's just their safety there there's
a sense of security there and there's
there's virtue in forfeiting a certain
amount of your personal judgment to the
group to which you have obligations
that's a good thing under most
circumstances you know and at least in a
lot of circumstances you know that's
what Duty is that's what you know just
fulfilling your obligations to your
people or you you you your unit or
something who are you especially if
you're an eighteen year old kid who just
got out of high school and you're over
there and you're in a situation where
you've got you know like in me lie
you've got officers you've got you know
not just your immediate officer but it
seems to be being reinforced by your
captain above you know your company
commander at the time in meal I there
was a there was a major-general in a
helicopter observing buzzing around that
place and so you know you're in a
situation where you say to yourself like
Who am I to say that what's going on
here is wrong it seems wrong to me
because of what I learned from my mama
or whatever but what does that mean like
I've got a captain I've got a lieutenant
I've got my sergeants I've got this
Major General in the air and you know
maybe I'm wrong maybe this you know I
just got here four months ago this was
my this is Charlie company's first major
combat operation they really hadn't made
contact direct combat with the enemy and
it's the first time any of them have
seen combat for the most part and I
think it's uh there's certainly a
certain amount of weakness that's
involved like you were talking about but
I also think there's a certain amount of
moral confusion that happens and that's
that's there can't be that kind of
confusion like that is where leadership
has got to take over I can add another
layer of complexity to this okay so so
first of all I do think that the well
Napoleon said if you execute an order
that you know it's wrong and when he was
talking about it he's not talking about
something tomorrow he's talking about if
I do something where a bunch of my men
get killed because the general said to
do it and I do it I'm culpable so that's
that's pretty clear that if your boss
tells you to do something that you know
is gonna in napoleon's case it was get a
bunch of your guys killed then did you
say no and if you do it you're culpable
for what happens you could say the same
thing if if I get told to do something
that's morally or ethically wrong and I
do it well guess what then I'm
responsible for that what what becomes a
little bit complicated to me or adds
another layer of complexity is this if
I'm going to Sand Creek and I'm with
Chivington and he's or shaving Tanisha's
hey we're gonna go there and we're gonna
execute this and we're we're gonna kill
these guys we're gonna we're gonna
conduct a rate and I don't believe in it
okay so I say you know what I don't
believe in it I don't think it's the
right thing to do I think that we've
made enough peace with them we've caused
enough problems that's their land
I'm not going okay so now you don't go
because you didn't believe in the
mission well now who's out there
conducting the mission everyone that's
going out there to conduct the mission
is people that are compliant with what
he's saying so you would be you would be
morally a better person if you said okay
I'm gonna go ahead and do this because
if I don't I know it's gonna be someone
that's totally compliant with Chivington
and I'd rather be there to at least
spare some of the people which we know
people did and so there's there's a
little complexity now I talked about
this in the business world two people
say you know my boss told me to do this
and and I I think it's a bad idea I
don't think we should do it okay so are
you gonna get put off the project are
you gonna get pulled to a different a
different Department where you no longer
can take care because you yeah this is
too hard on my people I refuse to do
this okay that's fine you refuse to do
this I'll put someone in there that
won't refuse and you no longer can
protect your people and your people in a
worse situation so you know the whole
organization is degraded the whole
organization so you raise your hand you
make your protest but sometimes
you've got to say okay I've made my
protest and I understand that you're
still wanting me to do this and even
though I think it's the wrong thing to
do I'm gonna proceed down the path
because I'd rather me be able to
mitigate as much of this problem as I
can then have somebody that's just gonna
do do do this to the fullest extent that
you would want them to do so there's
another additional complexity there that
it gets involved absolutely because
sometime as you said just denying you're
just making yourself feel better but the
reality is that plan is gonna go ahead
you are the only thing that stand in the
way of that plan going to the 100
percentile you can bring it down to 50
you know he's still gonna feel ugly
you're still gonna feel part of
something you don't want to be part of
but the only thing you do by refusing is
patting yourself on the back and say am
I not a moral guy it's like yeah but no
cuz you know it's like the thing is you
can use that power in that situation too
for something that is better than if you
just look yourself in the mirror saying
how great you are by not doing it and in
fact that's what was pretty incredible
about the Sun Creek story
Silas so you know they he's told right
before you know won't stay home you know
nobody's forcing you just stay home
don't be part of it and so and Kramer
and some of those guys say no we want to
be there we want to be there to observe
may be able to make the choice on the
spot and and it makes a huge difference
right there my feeling on it just sort
of looking at it all from the outside is
that especially in a counterinsurgency
war that without strict military
discipline and strong leadership that
abject savagery is gravity will take you
there that's where things will head on
their own unless you are supremely
focused on discipline and leadership and
education and those kind of things that
you don't have to you don't really have
to ask the question how can this kind of
thing happen the real question is how
does this not happen all the time right
how is it that American soldiers in Iraq
and you you know you go into Iraq and
they're seeing maybe maybe husbands and
fathers that they
folk to the previous day that they know
are innocent not part of the fighting
and they see his wife beheaded and him
with a power drill hole on the side of
his head how our American soldier is not
going and executing reprisal attacks
against these people all the time how is
it not just completely getting out of
hand and like that to me is by far the
more interesting question I don't have
to ask myself how is it that you know
somebody went and shot up you know that
the house of the person who did
something like that that's an easy
question to answer and and the the much
more interesting one is how it doesn't
happen all the time and it seems like
it's it has to be institutional it can't
come down to like you know institutional
culture right relating it to their sense
of personal identity and social identity
with the group that this is not who we
are that if I do this it's not going to
win me any any kudos from my teammates
or anything like that they're you're
gonna look at that as a betrayal because
I'm bringing dishonor upon us because
this is not what we're about and they
have to be able to look at it that way
and if they don't know that they don't
know that by doing something like that
they're going to you know they want to
blend in with the group they want to be
accepted by the group they want to be
looked at as somebody that can be relied
on and that has to mean following the
rules and doing the right thing yeah
well Daniella you pointed this out
earlier you you said well this seems
like it's just the communications aspect
is so important and that's a hundred
percent right so as we all know the the
strategy in the Vietnam War for America
was to kill more of them than they did
of us and drop more bombs on them and
eventually they'll just break just a war
of attrition and and so the the strategy
was get rack up as many kill count as
high kill count as you possibly can so
that's the messaging that's the
messaging so when that's the messaging
that's the messaging in in Iraq they
were very clear about hey we're here to
we're not an occupying force we're here
to live
these people were here to secure the
populace and make sure that they can
have a free country
that's the messaging so does that
messaging always make it down to the
front lines no that's why we do have
incidents where think you know bat
horrible things happen absolutely but it
is about the messaging and it is about
everyone understanding why they're doing
what they're doing what their mission is
what is what is right and what is wrong
and you can be educated on that legally
hey you're not allowed to do this you
can do that but you can't do this and
then the other point that you made which
is well you said you've got to be able
to manage people in a time of crisis as
a leader but more important and you you
actually you actually asked a really
complicated question and then answered
it yourself and you did that like three
times and that one sphere of
conversation that you had with yourself
yeah yeah is is you said you know you've
got to be able to manage people in these
pressure situations and then you added
that but what you really need is culture
and you're right because you're not
gonna be there the leader is not I
wasn't with my all my elements on the
battlefield all the time they were out
there all the time without me all the
time without me they were the ones that
had to understand what they couldn't
what they couldn't do they were the ones
that had to make those hard decisions
they weren't calling my snipers didn't
call back to me and say hey Jacque oh I
see this with this guy they didn't even
ask their platoon commanders that they
didn't ask anyone they knew what the
rules of engagement were they knew what
our strategy was they understood and one
of the things that I told them you know
speaking of rules of engagement so our
rules of engagement was you know several
page legalese document written by some
lawyers in Washington DC or wherever and
you know I've got kids in my platoon
that are 20 21 22 years old you know a
high school graduate and they came in
the SEAL Teams like I did by the way and
so they're looking at a legal document
like that that it does it doesn't mean
anything to them sure you know my rules
of engagement for them was it very
simple make sure the people you're
killing are bad you make sure the people
you're killing are bad and what and then
I explain to them why that was important
and the reason why that was important
was because the day that some civilians
brought a headless body that it had
taken a 300 Win Mag round to the head in
their head was gone and they said this
was our mom or this was our
schoolteacher or this was our
neighborhood doctor and one of your
snipers killed them and they would
figure out it was us but first of all
our operations would get shut down so
selfishly we don't want to get our
operations shut down but more important
than the selfish reason if that happened
we would leave all the soldiers and
Marines that we were working with on a
daily basis that we are providing
overwatch for we've leave them without
the support that we had committed to
give them because we weren't allowed to
operate anymore because we weren't being
discriminatory enough with our fire so
the culture is so important people
understanding why they're doing what
they're doing is so important and if you
don't get that messaging into your point
then it dinelli if you don't get the
communication correct then you're gonna
end up in a world of hurt in the point
you just made make sure the people you
kill are bad is such a think about it
there are so few words right you say it
in like very very few words and yet it's
so central because you look at not only
sang creek or me lie but look at even
like half of the you know when the Nazis
invade the Soviet Union and then when
the Red Army does the counter and they
start invading Germany both armies do
horrible things to one another civilian
and the idea is well the Nazis did it to
our people so we did it to their swell
damn ma'am that you are shooting in the
head that she had nothing to do with
what happened to your people she's not
she's not the Nazi soldier who did it
she's not the bad one just because she's
from the same nation are you kidding me
that's not that doesn't make her a bad
person and I think that's part of the
problem with group identity that's often
that's why stereotypes are dangerous
because you start grouping individuals
into this mental category you may have
of like those guys are bad that
individual only fear some
physical characteristic with the other
one they share maybe they are even
related but they are not the same person
you know they are did haven't made the
same choices they haven't committed the
same action so the fact that you treat
older Cheyenne the same only the side
you treat all the Vietnamese the same
all the Germans the same or all the
Russians
that's where everything goes wrong
because you're not making sure that the
person you're holding is the bad one
he's not the one there's no revenge
there they are not the same people and
so and yet it happens over and over
again where people fall into this idea
of group mentalities well I couldn't
catch that guy but is one of their group
it's like no man there are individuals
that are involved there are not there's
no collective guilt of it's kind of the
same reason why for example terrorism
strike us as so awful in every possible
way because you're not going against the
guy do you have a grievance against
you're going against the guy from the
same nation it's like there's nothing to
do with one another you know there I
feel like sometimes group identity it's
one of those double-edged swords right
because on one hand there's a side of it
that we mentioned earlier maybe your
loyalty to your group and not wanting to
bring dishonor upon them if that's the
culture is what keeps you from putting a
bullet in the head of a guy you just
cuffed you might be able to appeal to
you know you can say to people hey we're
Americans and this is not how we behave
and you're appealing to their group
identity out there you know and that
nobody it's a double-edged sword but
that is a case in which you're using
group identities for as the good guys
and in granted yeah it may not be that
every single one from the country really
fit that idea but you're putting a nice
idea and they are encouraging people to
live up to it that's already difference
from while it's similar in dynamics to
them the bad guys and plug in everyone
into that group where do you know that
that person really fit that stereotype
that you have of that group how did you
make clear to your men when you said you
know make sure the people you're killing
or bad that they understood what was
meant by that
it is well there's first of all there
are specifics in the rules of engagement
and one of them is clear hostile intent
hostile act or hostile intent which
means this person has to be doing
something actively that's gonna cause it
cause a negative impact now you can tell
which people are bad you can tell when
they're starting to do something that's
hostile act or hostile intent you can
tell and these you know my guys would
they they knew they would err on the
side of like I'm gonna make sure that
this person is doing something bad but
you know we had some decent arguments
about the rules of engagement I had some
decent arguments about the rules of
engagement up the chain of command
because the rules of engagement were
applying to all of Iraq and Ramadi was
not like the rest of Iraq at this time
in 2006 and you know if you've got
someone that is for instance observing a
location with binoculars right if you're
observing if you're in Baghdad and
you're looking at a location with
binoculars you're gathering intelligence
which is which which could be considered
which is not considered a hostile act
it's it's it's the intelligence
gathering you might suspect the person
being bad but there's there's no way to
prove that in Ramadi if you saw somebody
that was looking with binoculars at
friendly forces they weren't gathering
intelligence they were absolutely
coordinating attack an attack and that
is a group that is a big difference
because that is a hostile act and it's
damn sure hostile intent and so you know
those are the kind of things that I
would discuss up the chain of command
and we would provide them the resources
you know it's I talk a lot about playing
the game right like if my boss tells me
to do something I'm gonna play the game
woman I'm gonna try and do it and and
and occasionally I'll get the question
of like well but what if you get told to
do something that you really don't want
to do what if you got told to do
something that you didn't that you were
opposed to right what if you got the
order to go to the meal I mascar and you
got the order
well yeah they'd say no I'd say no and
first of all
that doesn't happen the closest it's the
closest example I have to that happening
was for me in Ramadi we had been told
that we had to take a certain number of
Iraqi soldiers with us on every
operation we conducted because we were
trying to turn the war over to them and
so they needed to get out there and do
operations and they were telling us they
were putting this this rule all over
every American unit in Iraq you needed
to have an Iraqi face on every operation
so what did the Americans do what did
what did the American units do what they
did was they say okay yeah we're gonna
take our platoon of 40 guys and I'm
gonna take two Iraqis with us and
there's your Iraqi face well that
doesn't move the war forward they were
obeying the rules so the the senior
leadership figured this out and said no
you guys are playing games here's the
new rule for every and I forget what the
number was they made a ratio for every
seven Americans that you have or for
every one American you have to have you
have you have to have seven Iraqis or
there was some number some ratio and in
Ramadi some of the units of Iraqis that
we were working with only had 18 guys or
17 guys and so that would have been me
sending my guys in the field with two or
three SEALs only which sending if you've
got a if you're gonna go into a bad area
and you're gonna who you gonna send
because you want to have a radio man you
want to have a medic you want to have a
guy that can call for fires you want to
have a leader and you want to have a
couple happy heavy weapons guys that's
that's six or seven guys right there
minimum right and so when the chain of
command told me hey you gotta do this
ratio I looked at the ratio and then I
said hey guys in Ramadi that's that's
not a good idea and here's why I'm not
gonna send my guys in the field without
a corpsman or without a radio man or
without a JTAC or without a machine
gunner I'm not I'm not gonna do that and
you know what they said they said that
makes sense Jocko you proceed like if
you articulate yourself correctly then
you can get your point across now head
they said to me hey listen no you're
only allowed to do this well then I
would have objected further up the chain
of command and I would not have put my
guys at risk to do something that didn't
make sense I'm not gonna do it
and and again that's what I always
encourage military people but not just
military people business people if
you're the CEO of a company and you've
given some directive that you don't
understand the full depth of the
directive that you've given and your
frontline someone somebody in your front
lines realizes that's gonna have a
hugely negative impact on your company
do you want them just to follow orders
you absolutely don't want them to
followers you want them to raise your
hand and say hey boss this doesn't make
sense and the thing yeah you say it
about yeah you don't want to surround
yourself with yes-man which makes
perfect sense then again it's it's one
of the things where you really need to
have work on yourself because the
reality is that most people have an ego
most people don't like to be told hey
boss sorry but that doesn't sound right
is like what do you mean you know
there's that reaction is like stung in
their pride which of course that were
all bad decision-making start going but
is a very normal reaction you know what
I mean is like most people have to one
degree or another and ego and especially
if like your guy
maybe phrase it maybe they are right
right they make a point where they are
pointing to something in your plan that
doesn't work but they phrase it in a way
that's kind of blunt so a you don't like
being reproached B you don't like the
tone by that point even to their content
is perfectly correct you're not hearing
it because it's like you have a better I
don't like you first you're criticize me
and then you're going about it with that
tone the guy is just saying things
plainly out they are maybe it doesn't
have a bad tone he's just not continuing
like slowly changes saying hey let's see
it this way and and you know what a guy
not cuz I get that I get that kind of
question all the time with all the
companies we work with all I got this
guy and my boss has a big ego and I
can't correct him and because he just he
just gets a fit well first of all when
you just like you said if you've got a
big ego and I tell you that your plan is
wrong I'm attacking a fortified position
and you're only going to bolster your
position stronger exactly and so don't
attack that position instead of simple
technique that you can use is say hey
boss I'm really not sure why we're using
this approach could you explain this to
me because I want to make sure that I
really understand what it is you want me
to do and it seems like if I do this
right here it's going to cause this wee
and I don't want I know you don't want
that to happen so could you just give me
a hand and fully understanding what your
plan is and that way your your your kind
of massaging their eagle a bit and it
opens their mind and that's all you have
to do is open up their ears that's the
goal is just to open their ears a little
bit so that you can start to have a
conversation with them and so that they
can going back to the whole topic of
today so that they can see you as a
human being with with an idea or an
opinion that actually matters as opposed
to seeing you as someone that's
attacking their ego and that ego thing I
mean if you think about the wars that
have been you know we always talk about
the wars that are caused by religion but
the wars that are caused by ego or are
also pretty severe and a lot of these
incidents that we talk about these
retaliatory incidences well who's gonna
be the first person to say you attacked
my tribe and I'm gonna let it slide but
that's that's that's a tough person
that's a hard position to be in you're
seen as weak you're seen as you you know
vulnerable you're seen as someone that
can be pushed around so there's that's a
very delicate game that you have to play
and that causes problems in that that
ends up that's it's a game that's so
hard to play in fact that most people or
many people across the span of time have
said no I'm not gonna say that they did
they drew blood we're gonna draw more
blood and you know and it I mean it goes
to what you were saying a second ago so
your people have to know that you're
gonna ask those questions of your
leadership and that you're doing that
work because they gotta trust you you
know that way when jaakko comes to them
and says hey guys I know this is gonna
sound a little bit weird but here's what
we're doing and here's who you're
bringing with you and this is what we're
doing they know that if you're telling
them to do it it's got to be done that
every discussion has been had that every
angle has been looked at that you've run
it up the chain of command and
registered your objections if they're
there but they know that jaakko is not
gonna send us out to do something like
this unless it simply has to be done and
I get asked this question a lot well
what do I do if one of my subordinates
has a question about the way I've
planned something and I don't have a
good answer what do i do then
I say well what you do then is you
listen to them you actually listen to
what they're saying because if if if
I've told you to do something and you've
then responded with some reason why we
shouldn't do that thing and I can't
explain away your reason then probably
I'm wrong and and as a leader this is
another thing where our ego plays a role
as a leader our ego says well if I admit
that I'm wrong to the troops they're
gonna think I'm up they're gonna think I
don't know what I'm doing the opposite
is actually true if I was in charge of
u2 and I presented you with a plan and
you guys came back and today that plans
not smart and I said shut up and do it
the way I told you you don't respect me
more you respect me less and if if I
came to you two with a plan and said hey
guys here's the way we're gonna execute
this and you say hey that's not a good
idea we should do it a different way and
I say okay well what do you recommend
and we come together with a
collaborative plan you don't think less
of me as leader as a matter of fact you
think more of me as leader you think
that I'm a humble guy that will listen
and take input and by the way bonuses
you all now have real true ownership of
the plan and we all feel good about it
and when you guys go in the field you
execute it to the utmost of your ability
because it's something that you own
it's amazing how everything you're
saying is it's as if you took a list of
all the traits of lieutenant Calley at
me lie and literally just said do the
opposite of all these things he was a
guy who couldn't take criticism from his
men harder person who asserted you know
who pulled rank anytime anything like
that happened who was a complete
transparent yes-man to his captain above
him who was just never asked any
questions I mean just right down the
line and as a result his men had no
trust in him so that when they got into
a situation it was chaotic they felt
like they were standing out on the
corner by themselves in a country they
didn't understand with nobody looking
out for them come I don't want to say
this in a way that makes it sound like
I'm trying to justify anything they did
of course not but you put men in a
situation where they feel like they're
in complete chaos and they happen to
have automatic weapons in their hands
well if I find myself in a situation
where I'm completely overwhelmed by
chaos that automatic weapons probably
gonna start to look like the best tool I
have for structuring my environment
yeah there's and and obviously this went
way beyond that the years ago I forget
how many years ago there was a shooting
in New York City I think it was 38
rounds were fired at maybe a homeless
person an unarmed person I forget the
situation but there's a lot of people
that just couldn't believe that all
these all these police officers shot at
this unarmed individual horrible
situation and again I always I've always
will say this like whenever I talk about
bad police shootings
I been on ride-alongs with cops I've
done hits with cops it's a freaking hard
job and and and I'm not a guy that like
I've done that a couple times here and
there but go out on that beat every day
and deal with those scumbags of the
world every single day and you're gonna
have it's gonna be it's the freedom it's
one of the hardest jobs in the world
that situation people say how the hell
did that happen well there's there's a
lot of tension in a situation the
emotions are high people are screaming
we're not trained well everyone is
sitting there with their slack out of
the trigger and when that first bang
happens it's a it's a chain reaction
that's one of one of the situations that
you know I would see with my guys that
was beautiful in Ramadi was they
wouldn't do that if if one of the
snipers took a pointed shot at someone
they would take the pointed shot and the
others would hold fire check fire until
you know the situation either evolved or
ordi escalated but the the army was
always quite impressed with the fact
that we would take really surgical shots
at bad guys and there wouldn't be you
know a massive amounts of collateral
damage again sometimes it's unavoidable
but maybe you can talk a little bit
about things I think that's one thing
that gets really lost on a lot of people
saying I think there's a lot of
propaganda that helps it get lost you
know there's no question that there's
been an evolution and our values in our
relationship to these kind of things
over the years you go back to something
like Sand Creek in 1864 there might not
have been a whole lot of people shedding
too many tears over what happened you
get up to me lie and you know there's
some controversy and
there's some you know there's a cover-up
all those kind of things but once it
comes out and it's laid bare and the
evidence is clear things had changed
from 1864 and that that incident and a
few you know other incidents that were
going on it made it out or a few
pictures that came out it turned people
against the war they decided that this
is not worth putting our men in a
situation where we're going to be doing
things like this this is not worth it
and you get up to today in the Iraq war
something like Abu Ghraib which is an
unacceptable situation but we're talking
about prisoner abuse that doesn't that
wouldn't cause the people who were
working that prison five years before
that the Iraqis who worked for Saddam
that wouldn't even you know they they
wouldn't even make it through their
filter right so I mean what was going on
there with the American soldiers it was
it was not okay but it wasn't walking
into a village in massacring 500 people
it wasn't you know brutal torture in the
same way that we would think of what was
going on before we took control of that
prison and yet our response to that in
the military's response to it once it
came out was pretty dramatic I mean is
theirs and it was quick it didn't there
was not as much of a delay as soon as it
comes out there's so there's a clear
shift that's going on there if if even
primarily from the standpoint of it's
just it's a breach and discipline that's
not how you behave yeah and and one of
the things that I'd talk about with my
guys is because you gotta frame this
right because you you know you mentioned
earlier that if you had to dealt with
this person that had cut the heads off
of the three-year-old girl yesterday and
now you you had him cuffed and knew as
him that guy deserves a bullet right
hey I agree with you that guy deserves a
bullet the problem is well number one
it's a breakdown in discipline but to me
more important and and what I would tell
my guys is if we behave that way we have
a significant chance of strategically
negatively impacting our war effort so I
get that you want to kill these bad guys
but more important than us killing these
bad guys is us winning this war and so
if we run around doing dumb things we're
gonna have a negative strategic impact
and that was actually always the biggest
worry as a leader is you don't want to
have some something happen where you you
know you you you drop a bomb on the
wrong area or you know and a bunch of
civilians get killed or you know you
don't want to have that thing happen
that's a real and the effort and lengths
that American forces go to to prevent
civilian casualties is it's incredible I
don't think most people have any idea no
they don't how that works and I think
that's one of the cool things about
creating a certain mythology that people
want to live up to the first time you
say it it may not be true it may be a
wishful thinking that you are those
people and you are not quite there but
as people keep repeating it and you ran
again and again with the fact that your
behavior doesn't match your ideals more
and more people will keep working on
trying to actually build that thing they
don't want to feel like hypocrites they
actually want to live up to that idea
and that's one of the things where while
sometimes people get turned off by when
you have this high-minded idea and this
very poor behavior they're like look at
that hypocrisy they say these things and
they don't mean it well sometimes when
you say it long enough people actually
do want to live up to it and they do
change their behavior so while the
theory may not match the practice when
you start if you keep at it long enough
the practice may try to him inch closer
to match in the ideals not a bad thing
I mean I I you can take it to a
political context right when people can
point back at the United States say
before the 1960s and before the Civil
War and point to the Constitution and
Declaration of Independence and these
high-minded ideas and people love to be
the cynical one that says oh yeah yeah
yeah but slavery and of course but this
and but that and yeah totally totally
true but the the the conclusion to draw
from that is not that the ideals don't
matter or that they're just on paper the
fact that those ideals were there was
what allowed the civil rights movement
to eventually come into being that's
what I you know gave us the room in fact
you could even say
that the thing we're talking about the
same thing that gap between ideal and
reality one way to talk about that is
hypocrisy but at the same time that gap
that opening is that's the opening where
people realize that and say there is a
gap between our professed ideals and it
makes room for that kind of positive
change right I mean you can go back
there was the Mongols were never ever
going to give up slavery because their
moral systems did not have room for them
yeah and so you you could go up to them
and say well how dare you enslave these
people and they're not gonna get
defensive they're gonna look at you like
you're crazy because there's no room for
that you know for that gap that idea
doesn't even exist right right and so
the ideals matter and when when when
they're broken you know again I think
that there's a motivation on the part of
a lot of people who are who are more
cynical than they should be given the
country that they're fortunate enough to
live in you know this is something that
you get from going overseas to a lot of
places is something certainly that I got
from spending so much time in Africa in
the Middle East for work is boy you come
back after the first trip to over to
those places and you realize you want to
kiss the ground when you get off that
airplane and you want to go around and
just hug everybody you see because you
are so fortunate to live in a place
where things that we absolutely take for
granted over here are miracles and you
know I think one of the things I did
really didn't want to do when I was
talking about me lie in that episode I
stayed very focused on the incident
itself sort of because I you don't want
to you don't want to be making excuses
for something like that you don't want
to make it seem like you're trying to go
up gloss over an atrocity but but you
don't want to give fuel to that idea
that like this is this speaks to like a
larger problem in our society because I
just don't believe well that's why it's
a dance right you know if you start
pushing the button to MA
in the direction of making apologies for
well after all we are good guys and
there are a few exceptions but look who
we are with stand for freedom and
democracy it's like yeah maybe but let's
not be so quick about sweeping under the
rug all the bad stuff let's look at it
the guys we instead push on the button
oh hey look at all the bad stuff that
means that all these ideals are crap and
it's not real and it's only pokers is
like whoa slow down a second yeah you
got a couple of points where you are
right by are also missing the boat it's
like it's almost like and that happens
in most discussion like in most
situations you rarely have somebody with
a hundred percent wrong is that they
take a partial truth and they take it
too far
and they lose perspective of the other
side of the equation like people don't
understand like American soldiers were
killed and maimed in situations that
absolutely could have been avoided if we
disregard our rules of engagement and if
we made like we made conscious decisions
to put ourselves at risk when we did not
have to because we were trying to be
sensitive to the environment and to the
people that were there and I don't think
enough people recognize the historical
anomaly that that is I mean that is just
you can't for thousands of years of
human history that is just completely
unthinkable you couldn't imagine
something like that and the extent to
which we go I mean Jaco has talked about
this before on his show the extent to
which we go to try to make sure that the
people you know the targets that were
that we're dealing with our targets I
think if more civilians had had an idea
of that people would feel a lot
different about about what we do over
there you know it doesn't mean that when
something happens like Abu Ghraib
they're not going to react against that
but they're gonna react against it from
a place of hey we're good country that
shit is not gonna fly all right that's
not you're not gonna represent us that
way and that's fine that's a healthy way
to respond to something like done it but
you know again a political situation or
whatever else is going on like you know
people have more of a knee-jerk reaction
of those things that you're talking
about I think in that sense it goes back
to that Dan Carolyn approach to things
right that ability to look at things one
way
just when you're getting comfortable
with the conclusions to say yes maybe
that is the conclusion we take but it's
not that easy there's also a 20% from
the other side that's not really wrong
and you should include in that and and
that keeps you thinking on your toes you
don't become dogmatic you don't become
thinking in purely black-and-white terms
you always have to have that nuanced
approach which and that's the problem
that's the other paradox is most people
take no one's to mean weakness then you
can't make up your mind you are too
wishy-washy you are it's now black it's
not white somewhere in there it's like
no that's also a weakness is the ability
to look at things both ways
and also make a decision that's where to
Macon seen has where it's valuable and I
think it's funny because so many of the
things that drug brings up are so about
really the kind of human being that you
want to become you know about self
perfection really because that's what it
boils down to which is then what makes
you a great leader because there's no
great leader without somebody was work
on themselves a lot and you know when
you break down to the principles nothing
sounds like it's that hard right it's
not like okay of course yeah I make
sense of that completely and yet it's
one of the things where while the theory
may not be that hard the practice is
unrelenting you have to be at it every
single day or its Wiis it was live
there's there's a great line in the
during that I was married to the river
or driving down owners there's the last
line that say my way is very easy to
understand and very easy to practice but
nobody understand it a domani track and
I love it because in theory yes it's not
that bad it's fairly straightforward and
yet there are so many steps along the
way where it's easy to go the wrong path
that is like the theory is easy the
practice is you need to put in the work
and there's no subs each of those steps
matters so much too because you know
Jaco was talking about escalation in
those situations the book about the war
in Chechnya you talk but I think the
line I and read the book until I heard
your podcast on it and it just it's one
of those things that when you hear it
it's so obvious but if you were to just
step back from the context a little bit
kind of seems ridiculous is which is
the savagery started when people stopped
shaving when soldiers stopped shaving
and I think part of the reason for
something like that is once it is it's
like escalations like a ratchet once you
stop shaving well now you're a unit that
doesn't shave anymore
okay whatever well what that means is if
you're a unit that lacks discipline well
now your lack of discipline is not gonna
manifest is not shaving you already
don't shave that's normal that's totally
normal so now your lack of discipline is
going to get to the next thing now I'm
not cleaning my weapons properly and
then pretty soon you're a unit that
doesn't shave and doesn't clean your
weapons properly and that doesn't even
seem like a lack of discipline anymore
that just seems like daily life and now
your lack of discipline or whatever it
is it's gonna go up to the next spot and
it can happen with you know it can
happen with just brutality and savagery
and things like that as well we're now
this kind of thing is just normal so if
I'm angry and it's totally normal for us
to be able to smack these prisoners in
the face but now I'm really pissed well
I'm not gonna smack them in the face I
smack him in the face anyway you know so
I'm gonna show my anger now by stepping
it up and mal okay if that's if that
slides and the leadership doesn't step
in well now that's normal yeah we're you
know we don't just smack soldiers we
punched and kicked soldiers but that
once that's the baseline it ratchets up
to that point well it's gonna escalate
from there because you know that's kind
of where it goes and that's why catching
those things right at the beginning and
letting people know that you know all of
these things matter I mean that's
probably the life lesson a lot of the
stuff do you even talk about it
everything matters it all matters yeah
and not it takes some time like I didn't
I didn't realize this when I was a 20
year old seal or a 25 year old seal you
know I kind of started getting the
indications and and that's why again you
know we I talk about training in
leadership because that's what this
stuff is you know putting somebody into
a moral dilemma with no training is like
putting someone onto the jujitsu mat
with no training they're just gonna get
destroyed whatever is gonna happen is
gonna happen and they have no control
over it
and you know you gotta think about these
things you got to think deeply about
these things so that you have some sort
of an anchor that's grounded that won't
get ripped out at the first person that
says hey shoot that three-year-old baby
you want you need to be grounded and
have thought about these things in a
deeper way and and you know what you
said about people swaying one way or the
other you're right and people actually
want to be led and they want to be led
even more so when there is a pressure
situation going on when there's
something that that you're not used to
or that people aren't used to some kind
of stressor some some kind of stress or
pressure if you can step up and lead at
that moment people are looking for it
they're looking for a leader and that
was I remember you were talking about
one of the guys in me lie the
six-foot-three guy and he's a natural
leader right he's a natural leader that
people kind of followed and what he
started going sideways and started just
getting completely savage and brutal
people just kind of okay you know he's a
guy look you know like okay that guy's
stepping up and and that's and there was
no one on the other end of the spectrum
to say hey no we're not doing that stop
and that's the biggest lesson from that
situation actually from both the
situation's you know and you know you
know people talk about is Louie how can
the leader be responsible if they're not
there you know yes the leaders
responsible whether they're there the
way they train the people the way they
educated the way they communicated the
culture that they set with those people
they're responsible and certainly these
leaders were absolutely responsible in
these scenarios I guess before we wrap
one last thing I want to ask you is
these days you say you work a lot with
businesses you can literally all you
know you're working primarily on the
concept of leadership and now to teach
people better tools to handle it how do
you go about it what's your what's your
is it primarily like a business oriented
approach now with major businesses that
are yeah will go in and do an assessment
and figure out where the
points are figure out where they're
having problems and and then we solve
the problems that they're having through
leadership and that's every single
problem in every single organization is
a leadership problem all of them whether
it's your P&L is upside down whether
it's your processes aren't working
correctly whether you got the wrong
people in the wrong positions it doesn't
matter well the problems are going to
get solved through leadership and
leadership alone and that's why we you
know that's why we're doing well because
if you've got a if you've got a P&L
that's upside down you've got leaders
that aren't paying attention to their
expenditures and and their income right
if you've got processes that aren't
working you've got leaders that are in
charge of those processes that are
allowing them to continue to exist
without refinement if you've got people
that are in positions that shouldn't be
in those positions you've got leaders
that are allowing them to be in those
positions without either being coached
and mentored and trained so that they
can lead or remove from those positions
and you can go right down the list with
any problem that any organization is
having there's a leadership solution to
that problem and that's what we do it
seems to me like it's definitely the
thing I'm gonna take away from the most
and listen you talk about this stuff is
one of the things that struck me as I
came in with a lot of questions in mind
I wanted to talk to you about like that
I started out with right you you've got
your guys you're going into a horrible
situation and there's these horrible
things going on how do you restrain your
guys from going and retaliating in these
terrible ways and your response and the
look on your face and everything to it
it actually like kind of threw me off a
little bit wasn't what I was expecting
because your answer to that really was
dude if I have gotten to the point where
we're there in Iraq and there's a guy
with handcuffs and I have to figure out
how to restrain my guys from doing
something I failed a long time ago you
because you took it as almost like well
you know you deal with it that was taken
care week how do we stop them yeah it
stopped him in training we stopped him
in boot camp we stopped him at Budds we
stopped them in all the way up it and I
don't want to make that's I don't want
to I don't want to make that I don't
wanna make light of that because that
that is a hard situation and when you
lose guys in a unit of 35 guys and you
got guys that are wounded
killed there is absolutely there is an
absolute fire that you have to control
because we know who's doing it we can
find them we can get out there and get
after them
and so we we do have to keep ourselves
in check we do I mean we had many
conversations of hey remember why we're
here remember who we represent remember
that if we get out of line we won't even
be allowed to do what we do anymore oh
so don't take it the wrong way that in
any unit any unit you lose people you
lose your friends you lose your brothers
that is an emotional it's an emotional
thing and you're in an emotional
situation already and you have access
direct access to unleash your emotions
if you are allowed to and yeah the you
know with the platoon commanders that
work for me with I mean those guys you
know Lefou wrote the book with me I mean
he absolutely had to had to sit his guys
down and explained to them hey let's
remember why we're here let's remember
that we could go to jail if we do the
wrong thing and nothing that we do here
is worth any of you going to jail for
any amount of time so I didn't mean to
make light of how hard that is and and
how difficult that can be and and it's
not just for me not just for for the
seals but you know the Marines the
soldiers that were there who are dealing
with like I said they're doing with
younger kids and and less with less
training and you know those when you
come in the SEAL Teams you came in
because you wanted to go to combat like
every single SEAL wants to go to combat
they want to be there I don't know if
you've ever heard my retirement speech
it's it's it's on YouTube but when like
I made a list and said hey if you want
to go over to the eastern part or Amati
and live in in a blown out bunker and
get into firefights every day put your
name on this list and I
down on the Roma came back 20 minutes
later and every single guy in the task
unit had their name on the list so we're
dealing with guys that every single guy
that's what they want to do now do they
get tired do they get combat stress they
absolutely do do they get scared yes
they do it's it's hard but we have a guy
that at least start from the position of
I want to do this this is my profession
the army you know you you definitely end
up with guys that are coming in the army
because they want to pay for college or
they wanted to get a job or they wanted
to get out of whatever hometown they're
in and and that's how they ended up in
the army again there's also a great
number of soldiers that are just as
eager for combat and certainly a great
number of Marines that are the same
attitude so each each one of those
people you have your own challenges and
it and it is hard and you do have to and
what goes back to what this whole thing
has been about as the leader you can't
be the one that's getting wrapped up in
those emotions you can't be the one when
yeah I'll tell you what your hearts
gonna be fucking broken when you lose
guys it's gonna be broken and you're
gonna want nothing more than to go out
and rubble cities and salt the earth so
everyone is dead and no one will ever
live there again but if you let that get
a hold of you as the leader your your
your team and your men are going to be
in hell that's where they're gonna end
up and so that's why the education the
training the understanding I mean it's
so many people contacted me after I did
the the meal i podcast that is it you
thank you that they play that meal i
podcast for leadership training inside
multiple military organizations it's
it's awesome I'm so happy that they do
that because when I came out with that
podcast I had tons of people that said I
didn't it didn't know about that people
that were in leadership positions didn't
understand know what the meal I'm asked
her was and it's a it's one of the
darkest stains on our history but you
have to talk about it and you talked
earlier about hey I don't want to make I
didn't really want to go into too much
of what led up to it because I didn't
want to make excuses man I went to
detail of why it happened because I want
everyone
understand all those little things how
when you cut those corners how when you
play the the telephone game with your
intelligence and you let people say
things that you don't put them in check
and you don't you let them use words
that are correct and you've people that
don't have a culture to ask why we're
doing this and you set those situations
up and you let bad leaders into Scituate
or in positions that they shouldn't be
in Caly failing out of OCS multiple
times like that's it that's it you let
those things happen and you're gonna end
up in hell and as a leader that's your
job to stop it yeah yeah it's a good
place to wrap it up man Mui Mui didn't
necessarily happen on March 16 1968 it
happened when Kali failed OCS it
happened when the intelligence failed to
get passed down properly it failed every
time somebody was allowed to smack
around a Vietnamese and they didn't get
called on it that's when it happened you
know the the actual acute incident was
the result of a long long process so
great man thank you so much thanks for
having me on thanks for you guys for
what you do and you guys put out
kick-ass podcasts and I appreciate
listening to them and you know you will
get to do this again something thank you
as well I mean I can tell you from my
own personal experience listening to
your podcast as well as a lot of guys I
know of all ages guys from high school
all the way on up into their 50s I've
one guy that I know is a huge fan you
know I don't want to just three of us
and it's getting a little sweaty in here
already so I won't get on my knees too
much but it's not an it's not an
exaggeration to say that you're changing
people's lives so thank you and keep it
up and we appreciate it
have a great affect on me personally so
thank you thanks probably thanks for
listening thanks guys and that wraps up
the conversation and thanks for
listening and thanks to Darrell Cooper
and Daniela Bailey for organizing that
discussion and I look forward to having
some more of those types of
conversations in the future about
history and about human nature and about
leadership and in the meantime echo
speaking of leadership if people want to
lead themselves down the right path the
path yes do you have any maybe
recommendations for them sure
of course they do so we're all working
out right mm-hmm yeah every day yeah you
work out every day
yeah although I got sick you straight up
get a rest
yeah flu salute yeah you know what that
is yeah man I hear bad things yeah
you're shot dude I didn't get that amen
you know I hear mixed reviews about the
whole flute deal either way you're
obviously better you seem better oh I'm
better which is good because now you can
get back to working out and when you get
back to working out you still want to
maintain your joint sick or not sick
maintain your joints that's what I think
I think everyone would agree with me on
that one and the way you maintain your
joints is to take joint supplements like
krill oil Jocko super krill oil that's
the good one
chocolate supplements that's right also
a good supplement called joint warfare I
take those every single day men every
single day no pressure no slack no slack
unless you run out but here's the thing
you don't have to run out anymore you
said you get the subscription situation
every one 30 days 60 days whatever
however much you use or whatever you
gotta estimate and then boom you do your
subscription you get one in the mail
every month never run out maintain the
joints important more important than
your power mass gainer 5,000 hmm I think
so yeah
also you want some cognitive
enhancements which you do you do you
totally do whether it's like you know
cell phone signals and you know
pollutions pollutants from cars
I say mess up your brain sometimes you
need some cognitive enhancement Jacques
was another supplement called discipline
it's a pre mission car named hands
physical enhancement cognitive
enhancement all in one boom and it
tastes good boom take it I would say
take that every day you take it before
stuff so you
pre-mission indicates you take it before
you do something where you get before it
before I do a mission yeah that mission
could be going to work with a company
mmm like hey I'm gonna need to be on my
a-game mentally because we're solving
problems we're digging in the leadership
situations we'll find out what's going
on any game has got to come also jujitsu
yeah but the people always say well you
know I thought you didn't take pre-op
workouts and I don't not for a workout
oh yeah for the workouts I mean I might
do that one out of every ten workouts
maybe even 20 would I take some kind of
a pre pre workout yeah it's because when
I wake up in the morning I'm not hungry
mmm yeah not even thirty I mean I drink
water but I'm not like I don't feel the
maybe or some yeah Jack me up there in
the workout yeah I'm just gonna go get
it
yeah and you don't really drink coffee
so you don't even have that situation
yeah no I don't like coffee
people want ask why I don't like off you
don't like the taste of it tastes
horrible yeah so what that did is it eat
like it made you or it didn't allow you
to get into the coffee system because
really what it is I mean everyone says
it's an acquired taste my question is
when something's an acquired taste how
many times do you have to drink
something that sucks before you like
okay I like this now before you acquire
this yeah yeah man and there was enough
to me there was no it wasn't like hey if
I can get this if I can start liking
this yeah I'll be I'll be stronger
no that wasn't gonna happen I was like
hey if I start liking this and I'm
spending $4 a day at a coffee store yeah
no not happening
well usually I mean like beer right when
you first drink beer typically yes I
don't I'm not good with any acquired
taste not chocolate milk chocolate milk
right off the bat everyone immediately
yeah way to try them all yeah and that's
probably why you make things taste good
cuz you don't you're not down for now
acquired situation or taste well okay so
like beer
coffee the same deal because there's a
there's a benefit beyond just the taste
so beer is like yeah you get drunk or
whatever and people like that but it's
like paying the beer is kind of
barrier like I wish it tasted better
Baba that's why they do jello shots you
know get in there
anyway so after a while you're like you
know what I'll endure the taste to get a
good eventually you like the dish you
end up liking the taste because you can
kind of recognize certain you know
there's all kinds of ease
same thing with coffee you kind of start
to like the taste because originally
initially you want to get the boost the
caffeine boost well the good thing is
with with the products that we make just
know they're not acquired taste it taste
good direct delicious you just get after
it from the get-go
yeah and just this discipline
pre-mission is no exception tastes good
it's like a lemon lime is that the
official official in Midland officially
yeah that's a good one because that's
like a real like broad like we're gonna
like the lemon like yeah like it takes a
weird odor not like lemon not that they
have issues
yeah you're probably missed but
nonetheless it does taste good I will
agree with that
and I think it's one of those deals
where you can just take it even if it's
not right before some stuff yeah I just
drink it sometimes I'm just straight-up
want something sweet just rain it's all
good for your brain yeah is that a lack
of discipline I want something sweet
no because unless you think about you
want to break it down what makes
something a lack of discipline it's like
when you slit when it's like goes beyond
your intentions right if you intend to
do something but they're like oh my
immediate payoff is gonna kind of get in
the way or whatever then that's that's
why it's okay to be like tomorrow I'm
gonna have a mint chocolate chip
milkshake yeah it kind of is not today
tomorrow but if that deviated from your
original hole plan then its lack of
discipline like if you're like huh I'm
really craving a shake I won't have it
today but I'll have it tomorrow even
though the plan is doesn't entail you
having it tomorrow man it's like a lack
of discipline just on a bigger scale I
guess for more longevity
check nonetheless discipline it's good
tastes good yeah it's good it won't take
discipline to take discipline knows
learn same for it like cuz it's gonna
taste good is gonna make you you know
what it is when you take it
that's talking Jade about this it's like
a um you know how like when you're
searching for a word you know when
you're trying to explain something and
like let's say I don't know your brain
is off you're hungover or your didn't
get enough sleep whatever and you're
searching well what's that word again or
you forget someone's name like your
friend or something like this it's
almost like the discipline is gonna
connect those dots for you yeah and this
is what it feels like you know the like
you know you ever played the lottery
play powerball or something no you only
ever seen the ball yeah it's like this
big round cage that they spin and all
the all the balls fly on in there and
then they just kind of one randomly
comes into the little shoot there
that's what it feels like it's like
that's all the words and that's all the
words and then that correct words just
not sure he's not coming in there I mean
but the discipling shoots the right
words in there like know like one speed
boom boom boom hey I'm saying that's
what it feels like take this one win the
lottery yeah sure yep same exact thing
nonetheless is good get that at origin
main dot-com that's where you can get
all this stuff origin labs they're
producing it you know by the truckload
for us also on Origin main comm there's
some good keys on there really good keys
only keys I'm worried enough forever
forever she straight up and they're made
in America by the way the Cotton's made
in America sown in America Lewton loom
is not a verb woven woven yes with the
longer the wrong word Lottery just
popular there do a verb maybe that is
proactive yeah yeah see hey well
Shakespeare made up a word everyone's
cool with it right almost on that came
cool and you can make words yeah all you
need is people to sign on so you know I
wish the cotton is straight-up loomed in
America and saw me know were assembled
in America they're made in America
straight up
Diggy's those rash guards on their
compression gear if you will pants and
tops by the way it's not just cotton you
know that's why it's so different
yeah because it's it's it's a hybrid
blend yeah yeah it's not just cotton
so yeah there's a that that's why the
material dries quicker that's why it's
antimicrobial yeah it doesn't smell bad
that's why it would dries out quick
that's why it's lighter cuz it's it's
made from the get-go for jiu-jitsu yeah
so yeah and that is a big deal if you if
you take jujitsu and you even just pay
even that much attention to that kind
stuff it makes a difference yeah and
then try go back to your okay you're
gonna be like bro I don't even do that
to my origin key sticking with it that's
why I'm sticking with it
also it's being jiu-jitsu there's an
emerging camp coming up except or August
26th through September 2nd this two two
sessions right early late session I'm
going Chuck are you going I am going
yeah Rhona both sessions poor Chuck was
so mad he couldn't participate last time
at her rib yeah it was almost like
something was there just bothering you
the whole time just a little bit no no
no a lot yeah yeah well you don't show
it that much but you could tell well
yeah yeah I wouldn't say I'd let it get
to me right but it definitely bothered
me it would show
every once in a while unless y'all could
be there in full effect this time and
yeah I'll be there and we can immerse
ourself in jiu-jitsu that's what it is
it's not a bootcamp
August 26 through September 2nd yeah
that's a good one Origen yeah so go to
origin man calm you can look at
literally all of the it's immersion its
jutsu immersion camp II you can only do
jujitsu
how many did it how many hours a day can
you do jujitsu why in real life or in
the camp in the camp and in real life I
guess technically in the camp you can do
it for 24 hours really yeah okay
technically if you okay now
realistically what do you think someone
does two or three hours in the morning
and 2 or 3 hours in the afternoon
Ramez 2 hours in the morning two hours
in the afternoon two hours in the
evening six hours a day yeah you'll be
sore
yeah after it which you're not obligated
to do but you that's the freedom you
have and that's how good it is
yeah and that's the thing man so you
know I like you let's say you for
example yeah and you're like hey I want
to roll two hours in the morning two
hours afternoon two hours at night I
but you think you can't just decide to
roll you got to roll with somebody
otherwise you just rolling by yourself
so that's a problem in the real world
not everyone you know but Brett this
camp oh maybe some more yeah every
single time finding people by the way
all levels boom
so yeah get some even if you've never
done jujitsu ever still go and learn
some gym get off to it it's a good way
to learn the ground running the
immersion well yep fully say or Jemaine
comm check look at all this stuff and
you know Dave Burke's coming by the way
yeah yeah I'm looking forward to them
Lister immersion jujitsu in time Dave
Burke calls me a seasoned name pop up my
phone it like you know every once a
while you'll run into that guy who can't
give you a few my gosh yeah kind of like
brightens your day no I don't know else
is coming I donno if JP he's gonna call
my life
ya gotta check the schedules yeah gotta
block the EF team schedules yeah they'd
be good if both of them come baby I'm
noticing they've been getting their
trained on trying to train yeah man
that's good also speaking of training if
you want some good fitness gear mix up
the workout get more creative with the
workout with the movements and equipment
go to on it calm slash chocolate get
yourself some primal bells I highly
recommend by the way someone hit me up
because we had this conversation last
time you said that my workouts were
boring yeah and someone kind of sided
with me just so you know cool because I
said the workouts can be boring if
you're boring sided with me yeah just so
you know
well they're right and straight up
you're right because I think we kind of
concluded that to where yeah you know if
you're boring or if you intentionally
make it boring yet sporting that's how
in fact the board the board um and the
boringness of the workout can be part of
a certain type of training you know it's
like a mentally that's a whole big thing
and I was irresponsible to a huge you
ever do you do you ever do a workout
word you just do one movement the whole
the whole time no oh yeah wait there's
some mental metaphor there's some sort
of like
there's definitely something to do that
mentally yeah you know like I'm just
gonna do five hundred repetitions of
whatever this is
actually yes I have it was snatch so
here's the thing though it was I care
about scotch No Oh Barbara Bell yeah
okay
it was a Cross Fit 500 snatches yeah
that's how it was that's my job anyway I
forget how me it was a dumb amount put
it that way
well at the time I thought it was anyway
I forget how much it was probably used
by like 20 I think it was 250 oh you
powered through those last five reps
though what that was it the whole thing
super sore the next day yeah but that's
it yeah snatch it's not just kind of a
fun exercise though that's the thing
yeah well but the movement is like it's
more dynamic than just um you know like
the thing with exercises like the snatch
if you're not focused
oh this one's real simple but if you
don't focus box jump okay if you let
your mind wander during a boström yeah
next thing you know you got a 8-inch
savage scar yeah yeah yeah
very true you ever near-miss a box
jumping it like wakes you up I don't do
that much box jumps probably used to I
used to box jump like a savage Jack does
your back or your own perfect super
stoked that I know that now nonetheless
there's some cool workout equipment gear
on their boring workout or not get
creative boom look in there a lot of
stuff that was just on there not
yesterday's day before
good good good website good info too by
the way on it calm slash choco good spot
good way to support also when you get
these books
I think I'm redesigning the website good
think so
I think it's old now there's the
anticipate list for that
while you try and get around to it
rather website was old-looking
since day one by the way anyway back to
the point when you get any of the books
that we review including Jacques actual
books where the worried kid
extreme ownership the Field Manual all
these books look I'm gonna list it on
the website and the books are listed by
episode in the book section you just
click through there when you get a boom
good way to support takes an Amazon
Prime one day shipping boom good good
way to support too but yeah come through
there good way to support also subscribe
to the podcast if you haven't already
seems obvious I know but some people
haven't subscribed and they're not
obligated to but if you do want to
support your subscribers good way also
on YouTube I want to say subscribe I'm
talking the iTunes stitcher Google Play
all that stuff and YouTube so don't
exclude YouTube the video version of
this podcast which you've been pretty
motivated on lately will stay active
sure I don't unless I am disciplined
with it but I am motivated too because
you know I understand the value of
excerpts now someone emailed the other
day hey this excerpt of not joining the
military or something about regretting
not during the military this is what he
did he had I think had like a medical
thing where it's like oh he couldn't
pass her whatever but he still could do
work for the military within other like
I mean you know did you became like
electronics technician for the military
even though he wasn't in the military
yes sir yes you were saying so like
those little excerpts can kind of offer
this info whether it be advice or just
spark other questions and people maybe
they wouldn't got it maybe they miss
that episode or maybe they just weren't
interested in actually missed an episode
somebody pointed out somebody made a
really funny meme that it showed it
didn't show you make an excerpt but it
showed like someone discovering an
excerpt and like wow this is awesome and
then it said oh no episode number
attached to this excerpt
so meaning hey glad I got the excerpt
now where can I find this or in the
future we may want to add the episode
number in there yes so did you know that
there was a big meme war no wars I mean
more I guess and I can't really follow
it a hundred percent because it was all
in reddit and but I read an article
about there was like a legit me more
what's a more well me more as different
memes going back and forth at each other
but there was a me more and I've seen a
flood somebody asked me one time they
had a they had a a ballcap you ever seen
the ball caps that say you know Vietnam
War veteran or you know Afghanistan
Operation Iraqi Freedom War veteran or
something like that someone wrote me a
sent me a picture and said is this is it
offensive for me to wear this hat and
the hat said you know survivor of the
meme Ward and look like it's like a
little better than Zach and I kind of
like no man as far as I'm concerned
you're good yeah don't know what you've
been through bars like I don't know what
the means more is I will I'm gonna look
into it anymore on reddit yet apparently
it had to do with sequels I can't I
can't say the whole I don't understand
it well enough
but I understand it well enough to laugh
yeah and think it's funny I think it's
very compelling 100% those means are
funny men yeah real funny that's good
that's a good thing
nonetheless excerpts I do put the
episode on there by the way saying when
you go and when you go to a YouTube oh
you got to go to the read more or
something you gotta click on read more
that's the thing so it looks like by the
way I was reading YouTube comments the
other day oh and fold it's a wacky way
someone wrote why are we even making
these comments Jaakko and echo don't
even read them guess what
joker reads them I read up thing there
you go me more what's going on I had to
do something take some kind of action
let's just read the comment actually
that makes sense but here's the thing
about YouTube comments this isn't new by
the way so a lot of people know this
rating where YouTube comments seem to be
maybe there's probably other forms and
where they get worse but YouTube has the
most potential for terrible comments and
for no reason to so but isn't it because
it's completely unregulated ken right
yeah well in other words on a Facebook
comment or on a Twitter comment
generally it's your purse you're you're
a human being
yeah on two on YouTube you're just
you're just yeah you can create an
account really easy and they can't
really yeah so it's anonymous you know
it's you know close to anonymous so the
the key is or the kind of the thing the
result is like if you're gonna read
YouTube comments on your your content
order you gotta gotta gotta have fix in
in real thick skin because they get it's
like they're trying to hurt your
feelings like they're trying you know
they are they can be that's the thing
people are creative and creativity is
just is a really broad thing and people
that when they use creativity to try to
like try to get you they can if you
don't have thick skin and I've
experienced this K you don't remember
what I used to do the cannot though show
ya right so that's a anytime you're
doing like comedy stuff or I don't know
like any kind of couldn't like creative
stuff to me your stuff now is really
hard to be like good jokes and try to
like you know so it's kind of easy well
I think you we kind of have it easy in
that way in that way because if
someone's like chuckles so stupid or
something like that they make themself
look dumb because it's so obviously not
stupid
but when you do like a comedy thing or
to me anyway I don't know so when you do
like a comedy thing or you know
something like that there's something of
the nature of hinata show or bikini
girls you know doing lightsaber fights
or something like that yeah people are
gonna tear that stuff apart and the
stuff they say it's like dang I didn't
even think about that but now I'm kind
of have a complex about my videos now
you know kind of thing so that's how I
started on YouTube by the way so I was
like kind of new to YouTube in putting
stuff on when a lot of cards got
shredded man her anything links and
here's the thing too but you don't
really have thick skin I would say then
that that time I was thinner in the
beginning I don't think you can really a
thick skin and unless they have the
heads up going in so and here's the
weird thing it's like most people they
like it because they're friends of
Hinata or something like that but then
when one
guy now after like 50 comments of like
haha these coolers ho this videos funny
or whatever whatever one guy says it
sucks you're like it sucks I know it's
you know get Steve it's weird how that
works
nonetheless the point is you reading the
YouTube comments is a wacky wild bold
adventure and I respect you for going
going on that adventure stuff
nonetheless chocolate reads them so boom
question answered right
was it a question or did I don't know
don't lose a statement same straight up
they don't know why we're even writing
anything Jocko and Eko don't even read
these comments meanwhile he wrote that I
was borderline like maybe I should just
respond for once and say hey what of
them right here reading yeah in the
darkness again of the darkness ruins
yeah man it's good maybe that's another
way to engage right I just figured like
YouTube comments um is kind of I don't
know it's not as authentic you know yeah
well good random what does your
anonymous yeah a lot of stuff which is
kind of a moment nothing less if you
want subscribe to the YouTube channel
for the video version and excerpts which
are valuable I've come to know the value
of excerpts and you know some enhance
excerpts qalam enhanced put some music
on there some text kinetic typography
you know what that is
well kinetic I know what that means and
ography I know what that means
yeah I'm putting it together yeah man
put it on a video it's like you know the
words kind of and get animated on there
yeah that's what it's called yeah you
like that stuff I like it too it does it
becomes kind of captivating some people
are really good at it man they do it
anyway nonetheless cool videos on their
channel subscribe subscribe good way to
support also chocolates door
it's called Jaco store.com it's called
jaw closed or the website is chocolate
or calm that's what I'm saying that's
where you can get your shirts same shirt
chuckle wears everyday the victory MMA
shirt you can get it there boom also
discipline equals freedom get after it
some bumper stickers on there decals on
their hoodies on their women's stuff on
their patches
velcro be nice
I haven't seen anything for waiting for
whereas guards are on their cashmere
blends directly picked from the high
mountains of Bavaria uh well the good
news about the meetings is that they're
in route in en route in rapid descent
you're on their word
they're on the way straight up put in
the order no we came down to the all the
stuff in the room they're on the way man
straight up here
yeah oh you know christmas is on the way
and just right yeah it'll be worth the
wait I think in my opinion unless it's
called Jocko store.com if you want
something get something check out stuff
if you like it get something good way to
support also psychological warfare if
you know what that is it's an album on
iTunes and stitcher and in wherever we
can buy mp3s
it's an album chocolate with tracks
chocolate tracks I don't think you can
buy mp3s on stitcher by the way oh yeah
don't go to stitch you then for it go to
Amazon music or something like that
or Google Play or you know wherever else
you can get them understand what I'm
saying yeah anyway it's a track with
jockle helping you okay when you go on
your path you have moments of weakness
we all do all of us do even Jocko I
think but when we when I have a moment
of weakness you know if jock is there to
be like hey look not yell I want
chocolate yelling me I want anyone
yelling really some people do I get it I
respect but personally and a lot of us
don't want chuckle yelling at us no need
to yell
no need right yeah yells is not
impactful
yeah well it's a short impact yeah I
have a long impact yeah and the little
deli is I think pragmatic telling me
like oh here's an actual reason yeah
well I should not miss this workout yep
and that's a good one I did not eat this
donut exactly right that's exactly what
it's one of my favorite Twitter things
of all time is that little girl from
Australia saying imitating me saying
she'll go coded
good 100% yes nice that's a good one
yeah notice you weren't yelling on
though no she kind of made it it's funny
the way she heard it was almost like
yelling you know is our shooter coded
nice yeah yeah very good
unless it's practical joke Oh telling
you practically and pragmatically why
you shouldn't skip the workout why you
shouldn't or why procrastination kills
you so it's like you'll be like oh it's
almost like you gained a deeper
understanding of the potential weakness
and you can get past it works 100%
success rate in my experience check well
also you've got if you want you can get
some chalk a white tee and you know what
sure it tastes good sure it's got
antioxidants in it but let's face it
there's no other drink that's
guaranteeing an 8,000 pound deadlift but
no other drink not that I know well so
you get some chalk away I get an 8,000
pound deadlift check next question a lot
of people do all kinds of work it out
they try and explain
try the triple complex do them they come
up with these big plans just drink
chocolate you're there no need to even
play around check books weigh the
warrior kid we talk about staying on the
path what's the path a lot of people are
looking for the path but what if someone
could show you the path well the fun the
fact is the path can be found and it's
simply and clearly put forward to you in
the way of the warrior kid books of
which there are two and they will put
kids on the right path is the book
everyone wishes they had when they were
kids
everyone everyone that's read it has
said to me I wish I had this when I was
kid I'm looking at me to meet you I
didn't have it how to just kind of
wander around trying to figure out where
the path is but no you don't need to
have that happen so a lot of the path is
covered in book one but now book two is
coming out way the war your kid - it's
called Mark's mission more lessons
learned control
your temper saving money how to get
people to stop making fun of you that's
important to know as a little kid right
controlling fear of failure because a
lot of kids you don't think is you when
you think a fear of failure you think of
like an adult
that's an old you know how to remove an
old foot want to step out man that guy's
afraid of failure like that that's for
kids even more so kids don't even want
to try something they're gonna afraid
they're gonna look bad yeah I remember
my daughter when she was 13 my oldest
daughter she was 13 years old and I she
was kind of interested in something else
like oh why don't you you know try it
she's like I'm too old to start she's 13
you know what I mean
so how do you get kids to come over that
well you you introduce them to these
books building a business that's
something that kids don't think about
very often they should be they should be
thinking about starting businesses
earning money when they're young
learning the value of money when they're
young they should absolutely be learning
about those books gonna make every kid
better it'll make them a warrior kid so
here's what you do you pre-order the
book now that's my recommendation Mark's
mission pre-order the book now there's a
couple reasons why number one you don't
it's happened with other books that I've
come out with if you don't order it
pre-order and guess what you go to order
and it's not out of stock and then
you're mad at me everyone do your supply
Advantage these are broken really well
they're jockle hey okay I'll take
ownership of that
guess what order the book and you'd have
it how's that that's my recommendation
so if you order the other thing that's
good about it is if you order it spreads
the word and more kids will hear about
it cuz there's no big advertising I just
got a thing the other day from somebody
it was a social media I think it was
Twitter you know you might want to check
with your I don't know what your
marketing team is telling you like I
don't have a marketing team over here me
and echo we're kicking it so if you want
to help spread the word order the book
it's due out april 24th it's way the
warrior kid to Mark's mission and if you
want to see a an actual warrior kid in
action check out Irish Oaks ranch calm
Aiden he's a warrior kid he's only 12
years old but has his own business
speaking to businesses
you can get his soap that he makes from
goat milk
very good silk anyway yeah it's got a
good model to the model of the soap is
stay clean sounds simple but you know
what there's a lot of layers there eight
don't forget the discipline comes
freedom field manual eating thinking
fighting working out life looks are my
life get the manual on how to live your
life the field manual discipline equals
freedom for the amp for the audio
version of that you can't find it on
audible because it's not there the audio
version of discipline equals freedom
field manual is on iTunes Amazon music
google play other mp3 platforms as an
album with tracks don't you know
also extreme ownership combat leadership
for business and life and on top of that
leaf babban and I are bringing out the
follow-on to extreme ownership it's
called the dichotomy of leadership
it's got knowledge and lessons learned
from the battlefield and business and
life you can pre-order that book right
now did you know that to pre-order it
now if you didn't know that you can
pre-order that book now comes out
September 25th again if you want to get
the book when it comes out order it now
otherwise it'll sell out and you'll be
mad at me hey I'm down you can be mad at
me
that's cool for even more leadership we
have national on front that's my
leadership and my leadership consulting
company me Lafe babban JP Danelle Dave
Burke you want us to come out to work
with your team email info at national on
front comm or you can check out that
website and of course there's the muster
which is our leadership seminar we're
only doing two year to this year
Washington DC May 17th and 18th San
Francisco October 17th and 18th both are
going to sell out they are going to sell
out so get registered now at extreme
ownership calm the entire rational on
front team is going to be there and no
we're not going to be in the green room
we're not gonna be sitting
back there drinking warm cups of milk no
we'll be with you the whole time
interacting answering questions will be
eating will be talking will be working
out just basically getting after it
as they say so come and get it at the
mustard and lastly new announcement roll
call roll call 0:01
September 21st in Dallas Texas this is
for current military law enforcement
firefighters paramedics other first
responders one-day leadership seminar
about leadership in a dynamic
environment so you can also sign up for
that at extreme ownership comm we thank
you all for your service and want to
give you a little bit back we look
forward to seeing you there and until we
see you at the mustard always see you at
the roll call if you have anything else
for us you can find us on the interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram and on feeble
hockey echo is at echo Charles and I am
at Jocko will Inc and thanks to everyone
for listening especially members of the
Armed Forces that put it on the line
every day to hold the line and to the
police and law enforcement firefighters
EMTs and other first responders thanks
for being there when we call on you and
to everyone else out there listening
don't just listen lead take charge take
a stand
raise your hand and raise your voice and
say I got this then take up your
position on whatever battlefield you are
on and get after it so until next time
this is echo and Jocko out
you